evan no i mean you know
you didn't have a good chunk over that
heaven i had to laugh you go to the
exactly i'm having a laugh right now
all right man i just i just got the news
i'm not mad at you i get what you're
saying
i get what you're saying i get what
you're saying uh yeah we're gonna do a
quick live sound check you know i mean
we do all our own tech
guys so uh we wanna make sure this [ __ ]
works uh let us know right now
uh i'm gonna do a quick sound check so
when i speak does it sound clear to you
guys are you guys getting me
clearly please go ahead what's good it
was good people what's good
yeah there you go there you go
people probably want to know why you
laughing well it's okay
they have no clue why you laughing right
now
oh you know i mean our lives don't stop
when the cameras are off you know so we
say stuff before we camp
yeah and we say stuff after so yeah you
know
things always said yeah and i'm still
laughing so okay
everything sounds good loud and clear
all right listen look look at that look
at that it was one of the few times
where we started live streaming there's
zero technical problems you can tell we
don't do twitch full time
all right hold up wait there's way too
many [ __ ] i gotta put on slow
mode because this [ __ ] is a hot
mess okay uh listen
we got to that point you know what i
mean
[Music]
all right we're gonna keep it a buck
with y'all these live streams there's so
many people now and we're gonna be doing
them regularly we're gonna be having a
lot of cool guests uh
get that bail out what do you mean
can you stop could you
stop um
so what we're going to do can i i don't
know hold up apparently your mic is dead
is my mic dead really
hold up really yeah my mic is dead
it's your mic picking up my mind
hold up hold up it's my mic check check
see you jinxed it
bet you guessed it i think you have to
be close to it yeah i'm like i'm almost
okay
yeah yeah we're not
[Laughter]
uh yeah i mean it looks like it's
working am i crazy
well maybe check the check the i
sometimes there's always one people that
is a goober goober it's like
they don't know they don't know how to
process their mics and their
like sometimes it's their mind that is
off all right let me try something
hello hello hello hello hello hello this
is me speaking now how does this sound
yeah i think it's fine hello hello hello
i don't think it's peeking i don't hear
it peeking at it it's not peeking
yeah yeah what's good what's good
there we go all right there you go okay
i fixed it
um all right now now they're just
trolling but yeah we just want to let
you guys know
listen my mic is not weak y'all y'all
better y'all better shut your mouth okay
shut your damn mouth all right uh
okay all right listen you know what if
it's low it's low [ __ ] it
all right i got no time for this anymore
you know that you have to you can
increase your volume
on your computer what you mean they can
they can put the volume yeah but it
probably is annoying if you were talking
really loud and then there's me talking
then they gotta
they'd be like this the whole [ __ ]
time sometimes you have conversation
with one motherfucker's louder than the
other one yeah yeah yeah listen i don't
know what's happening maybe i'll troll
at me so i'ma just let it go
what i will say is in the future we're
probably going to be doing some
some streams which are going to be
members only uh because of the fact that
there's just too many of you
[ __ ] and the chats move so
quickly
and sometimes you want to interact with
the chat and the jazz just crazy
okay um
so so so yeah that's what we're gonna go
with for now but listen we got a special
guest in the building you guys may have
seen our cut video where we had
a guest uh come on and he was uh
we didn't he was on the cut and then you
know we
reviewed the video and uh basically we
got in touch with him he said oh man if
you want to jump on you're always
welcome
and so uh we got the guests in the
building uh i'm gonna just drop a
message
hey be ready in two okay you know what i
mean
but yeah we're gonna bring them on we're
gonna ask them a couple questions about
the video if you guys haven't seen that
live
we'll do that afterwards we're gonna
talk about a few trending topics
and then from there we're gonna be doing
some collins okay
some collins so if you would like to
join the the collins shows all right
if you'd like to join the collins show
there's a link in the description you
guys can go there
jump on that discord and then wait in
the queue have your camera on
waiting in the queue and then we'll pull
you in okay
so and be ready all right don't win no
time
all right so we're gonna be doing a lot
of cool interviews a lot of some of your
favorite people people you've never
heard of are going to be bringing them
on
and so i think that's pretty much it for
my announcements anything else you want
to announce
no all right so uh we're going to bring
in our guest
let me just unmute this man okay because
he's
been out there waiting chilling not the
the what the audio oh
so we don't get no feedback sorry
brother
sorry for what it's not the ideal setup
it is what it is yeah i mean
all right all right here we go i got the
left one
you got the left one yeah sorry oh
[ __ ] i don't want to put this on my ear
i don't want to put nothing in my ear i
don't want to put my own earphones in my
own ear feel me
you don't want to put your own earphones
i feel like i feel like i got i got
those
i got those jellies that's what i hate
that they're fact i hate the fact that
they're called jellies
they defeated are called jelly yeah yeah
i hate the fact that they're called
jellies it's not such a disgusting word
jelly is a disgusting word jelly yeah
yeah you know what makes me think of it
makes me think of that dude from that
prison video was like
i like it when you suck my ass with jam
or jelly what the [ __ ] you
you remember that oh yeah it's a
sensational feeling yeah
when you get your ass up i prefer it
with with jelly but some [ __ ] like
syrup
and i will reach my climax i will come
if you suck my ass with jam or jelly
so every time i think of jelly i think
of that i never was a pb
peanut butter jelly dude no i just
remember the song peanut butter jelly
time
brother you know you know he died you
know he's a cousin of snoop
oh i don't know that he died in a
standoff which got the prison or the the
no the peanut butter jelly peanut butter
jelly guy huh he died in the prison
staff
he died in a police standoff okay
you could google that uh that's great
and and
snoop tried to uh yeah this is just me
again being a nerd about music
yeah and snoop was there to coming down
and he
okay and he died that's crazy yeah all
right
well uh folks we're about to get papa
with this live interview we don't want
to keep y'all waiting all right we got
the petty king himself about to join
uh hey uh it's wilmer right i actually
never did catch your name
hello whitmer are you there we heard you
yeah yeah i'll get here
cool if you want you can just uh try
turning your camera on real quick
if you can sure why not all right let me
just turn you up okay here we go
and then let me just there you go change
machines i mean all right
okay wait no that's not the one uh this
is the one wait
in the floor oh my god oh my god what's
happening what is happening with your
[ __ ] oh i know what happened i [ __ ] it
up
okay all right just give us one second
yeah
all right oh my god what's happening
okay here we go
let me delete one of these actually you
know what no i [ __ ] this up
there we go i don't even know what he's
doing don't worry bro i got this like
you just got to play tetris a little bit
you never played tetris bro yeah i
played that transplant
yeah this is what happens when you try
to jerry rig everything hey man what's
your name by the way we never caught
your name
uh austin or i go by vaughan too
okay okay yeah okay cool man yeah either
is okay
so why don't you give everybody a little
introduction why we know about you and
and how this came to be
how it came to be okay yeah
so i've done a couple cup videos already
for them
and they kind of already knew like how
my personality was and how it was
on camera and uh i wasn't even supposed
to be on this video how
it was like on a whim the the original
guy actually
uh bailed so okay a call two days
later and like the agent gal that kind
of like sets all this
stuff up she goes hey the guy
for this blind date video bailed and the
shoots on friday
um we think you'd be a perfect fit to
like
you know take his place and i said sure
[ __ ] it did you did you know you were
being set up
[Laughter]
they they did tell me that their she was
going to go through my phone and have
like full access to anything that
uh you know i end up allowing right and
wait they told you beforehand they're
gonna go through your phone
right yeah but i only had two days and i
didn't have any
real time because i worked two jobs i
had no free time during the week
to really kind of oh my god so wait wait
let me just make sure i understand so
because just because i make sure i don't
want to miss anything so they knew you
knew you were gonna
they were gonna go through your phone
and she knew as well
right yeah totally whoa okay i thought
this was like a surprise thing
it didn't look like a surprise and i
also just don't care because
i don't have anything crazy on my phone
like
that's what you think until they found
out about those screenshots [ __ ]
there ain't nothing weird about having
beautiful women in my camera roll it's
not just
the gals there's memes and there's
things that i think are cool
and i'm not i'm not cataloging any of
this [ __ ] like
i'm okay okay okay so so before we even
get to that okay so this is really easy
i didn't know this was a setup okay
so so they tell you
they're gonna go through your phone they
bring you on two days prior you come in
what were your your your thoughts going
in were you like i'm gonna just do a fun
video you're not like taking it too
seriously i imagine
yeah i ate um i was coming from
like my brother's birthday and i was
just telling him like hey i'll be right
back i gotta do this video shoot real
quick
and yeah i mean you're right i was not
taking this seriously at all
and uh the girl that i ended up getting
matched with like
wasn't my type so i just kind of [ __ ]
around the whole time
until the end of the shoot so yeah no no
join us some she wasn't your type no not
at all
okay okay oh well work out she works out
i mean
no is that all it takes for you we have
one hobby in common we [ __ ] yeah
yeah oh girl uh you like dancing i like
dancing let's go
i understand what you're saying just
yeah go ahead yeah sometimes that's
yeah sometimes that's all it takes or
you just you guys just gotta be cordial
but yeah she was not you know
attractive to me uh i didn't
bother really trying to really get to
know her because they only had so much
time to
really talk and i had to like talk
through
the producer guy through my headset
right it was until the it wasn't until
the very end when we actually were like
face-to-face
chatting so uh he was like the moderator
and he didn't always say exactly what
you said
yeah yeah yeah right well i mean i mean
he he he knows what he's doing he's
trying to get content so when he's
changing a few of the things you know i
mean it's to get a little bit spicier
you know right yeah yeah some colorful
editing is the best way i would put it
and to be fair i don't think you were
her type either
that's totally fine i don't i don't i
don't expect
you know living through my life to be
attractive to everybody
or me be attractive to you know just any
girl
on this side like 100 there's a lot of
you know variables that come into play
um i want to to to touch on that because
this is something that people said but i
thought
i didn't know if i necessarily agreed
they said initially
you were interested but after she said
some of that stuff you you got offended
so then that's why you
got peddled yeah this whole this whole
week has been
utterly hilarious just seeing how the
internet
has react to all of it like i have so
much to say because
i mean they're they're missing the mark
not totally
but like i appreciate
i mean for days it wasn't until your
video where i was actually getting
support and like love from the internet
like
for for four day four or five days i was
just getting
shredded and shat on in the comments
really
like it's not that i care i don't give a
[ __ ] like i had 50
60 friends and family tell me like oh
i just watched the video that was the
funniest thing i've seen in a really
long time and blah blah blah
like i cared a lot more about what they
said but
it was just weird to see that the
internet was just like
yeah but at the end this whole this holy
war against me in the comments like
so so so you really felt like everyone
were you getting like hateful messages
or things like that or was it just like
you sing the comments
i got no direct messages that's because
they didn't know what your instagram was
if they knew
they'd be like you got a problem with
single moms [ __ ]
i got a whole baby too exactly that good
good i
messaged the asian girl i was like man
like i wish
you guys like tagged my instagram
because i welcome that like
you guys just don't know me like uh
i honestly don't care what you know
people on the internet really
say because i don't live my life that
way so those people could people people
on the net be like that you know they
they be
taking one thing and then they will
message you because they're not fake
things that they would not say if you
don't face the face
so they could get reacted yeah yeah
yeah they can get crazy uh so so that's
interesting you felt like a lot of the
judgments against you were unjust in
regards to how a lot of people perceived
you through that video
was that a result of the editing or was
that result of just people being biased
in a negative way or is it a mixture of
both
what do you think ooh um
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to say uh a
mixture of both
i mean um
if the whole shoot was like maybe 90
minutes
so they really it was it was a pretty
lengthy shoot and then they
they only did what was like a six and a
half minute
video there was a lot more said there
was a lot more that we
kind of did and shuffled around and do
you
do you think the editing did justice to
what happened
or there's something that you like
like did the editing play in favor on
one side
than the other sure sure
uh
basically we want to know like you you
as somebody who's been behind cut videos
and like been a participant
do you feel like oftentimes the editing
is a representation of what happened
like to some degree
or do you feel like it's like shifty
because that is something that a couple
of people who've done cut videos have
said to us in the past as like people
who dropped on
yeah i mean obviously they they have to
make it you know
watchable and they gotta get the clicks
and i'm not i'm not offended by how how
the end result
was i mean all all of it still was my
words i still
stand by it like the only part
that they that they dared me dirty on
was
uh sorry sorry i think you cut out there
best part where i was like she got to be
fit
right yeah i said i said a lot more
following up to that like i like a girl
that can stand on her own two feet
she's independent she has her own life i
have my life
and we like respect that and then i was
like and you know she gotta be fit too
you know that that is that that is dirty
because it makes them sound shallow yeah
because like
it's like it makes it sound like it's
the only thing you said yeah yeah
it set the stage for all the audience
members
you know watching like oh this is gonna
be good this guy's a total
d-bag like god i hate this dude
i'm gonna keep watching and then
everything else that he says
is also equally terrible so
okay that's interesting that actually
does because imagine if you brought a
girl on and she was like you know i want
a man who respects me
who likes me for who i am who really
wants kids who's a family christian man
and who makes six figures and then they
only put he makes six figures
that would make her look like a gold
digger in some ways right
so that's that's an interesting thing um
okay so i think now we should probably
get to like some of the content of the
video some of the stuff that was said
that i thought was hilarious
um why do you think the the date started
off on
it seemed from the outside looking in
that they started off on such a petty
note
okay and and i thought it was
interesting that everyone like when i
saw the video in the comments everybody
was like roasting you and i started the
video i was like damn she going in on
this man
did you feel that when you were watching
it from the booth
from what i remember i i honestly did
not
really care what she said i i kind of
mentally checked out
the moment they revealed like her to me
like from the beginning like this is
your date
i was like silent for a minute and the
producer was like
austin like what are your thoughts and i
was like oh dude
i hate to like just to be honest like
she's not my type and then
blah blah blah right right and then from
there you kind of checked out
but what they had your reactions after a
lot of the stuff that she said so that's
why i'm asking i don't know if those
were actually
mish-mashed well together but yeah yeah
you weren't bothered by the stuff that
she was saying
no no i none of it hit home like
some people are assuming on the [ __ ]
internet it's just
i don't know my face my face doesn't
really hide anything
and uh it's hard for things to really
like get under my skin
or i don't know i don't i don't take
anything to heart so i didn't
really pay much mind about what she was
saying and what she was checking out
because it's just like
i don't know who she is i don't really
care what her opinion
is right right okay but outside of her
necessarily are you caring
did you feel like what she was saying
was petty period that's what i mean
right so like for example she's talking
about the screenshots on the phone
yeah i don't know if penny is the right
word i mean she's just
she didn't know who i was so just like
seeing those screenshots
maybe from a girl's perspective like oh
this guy's
[ __ ] red flags you know red alert
fire fighter fl flight response has been
activated like this guy's a [ __ ]
creeper
yeah it's like no like i'll scream
because all my friends aren't on the
same
social medias so right sometimes i need
to
take from twitter and send it over insta
or over
imessage or like i'm not keeping it for
nefarious reasons here that's a that's a
misconception that people have
people think we take screenshots because
we're like gonna stare at these pictures
and do those stuff like
first off we're taking you know
screenshots of stuff that's on a public
platform and then we're just sending it
to group chats
because like you said some people don't
have social medias we're not here
in the age of amateur porn and all this
other adults
you think we're gonna beat it off to
your ig pics like calm down there's a
hundred other people in the feed i don't
think
it was personally i don't think it was
really petty what she was saying
i i don't think it came off as
petty but the whole environment was very
judgy
you know it was the end but that was the
point of the whole thing right
it was the judge it was to judge you
right
so petty i wouldn't say petty but yeah
it didn't come off as very judging and
stuff like that you know you kind of
want to creep
just because of pictures and stuff like
that go ahead oh
i was just told i was just agreeing with
you yeah
and um i mean the whole point of the
video is just
getting the reactions of what you're
thinking but
being said so i mean we're all thinking
these things
and just yet to actually be put out into
the open
might be a little okay so so so
okay so then moving past that when it
gets to your part everyone was like oh
man this man
went instantly on her phone battery and
they're like even us i'm like damn this
man going full
petty right now so so so tell us about
that
okay yeah okay okay okay
she didn't go on petty i don't think she
went were you
where you guys were like oh he's going
he's gonna go in like
i'm i'm with you guys there like the
moment i got her phone i was like all
right
i'm just gonna [ __ ] around for the
entire time like
i'm just gonna go off on every little
bit because
i just i didn't care anymore i was i was
like i'm gonna have fun
i'm i'm killing everybody in the room i
was making everybody in the room [ __ ]
laugh the entire time so i was just like
i'm just gonna keep writing that you're
just being a [ __ ] disturber
yeah yeah yeah one [ __ ] punch line
after another i was just
wrecking it and i i got my amusement
from that so
right it was just really fun for me okay
not
i wasn't like trying to be mean to her
at all i just have no filter
and just how i talk and uh my friends
can
say so anytime you meet a single mom
you're like you got a whole baby
[Laughter]
is that really like something that that
you that's a deal breaker the whole baby
thing that's a that's a deal breaker
no babies i'm i'm not having babies for
like my mid-30s so
i i do not you know i don't want to be
the the father that stepped up
you know i don't want to be you're in
here
right now you're how old are you right
now if it's not too much
oh you can you can ask me oh yeah you
said you were 25 in the in the in
in the video uh 24. she's 20. she's 25.
okay i want to ask you oh that's
interesting did
did when you were brought on to do this
video
did they know how you did they ask you
any preliminary questions about how you
felt about single moms or anything like
that or no
no all they really asked was
what were my preferences and so i listed
and then i was like i work out and
they're like
oh we perfect because your date
also likes to work out and i was like
yay
everybody says they work out like that
is such a wide spectrum
i mean yeah yeah you just didn't expect
her to be [ __ ] yolked and like be a
personal trainer type [ __ ]
freaking jack yeah hey man lower the low
get lower on them squats [ __ ] i
was like
i guess i got back muscles like that
hold on
yeah but i i i really i mean she's she's
incredible for sure i mean
she's got some serious gains and yeah i
don't want to knock on that at all i
mean she she puts in a lot of good work
for
what she has so mm-hmm yeah all right
well
let's stop any other questions you want
to know man it's really it's it's it's
really fun to know about the process of
of the the whole thing it's weird that
they didn't ask questions before
like i don't know that's not really how
i would go about doing a video
but i i don't think they're trying to
make real messages
i think they're trying to find
interesting people yeah it's interesting
yeah
and you and they they went right on the
money with that because
you're interesting basically you you you
well you are
and what happened happened you know it
was really it was a fun video to watch
right right because right like like i
said earlier they
they knew what they were dealing with
they're like ooh let's just add a little
seasoning of austin in there
come out to be a perfect the the moment
we were done like the the cameras cut
the producer like like it pulls me off
to the side and he's like that was
hilarious he's like i [ __ ] can't wait
for this to be
i knew what i did i told you during the
video the producers in the back like
this
yeah we bout to make some money he'll be
about to make some oh yeah
he was rubbing his hand like birdman
just like yo let's get this cheddar
you already know that boy i texted my
friends and i was like holy [ __ ] that
was the most fun i've had in a long ass
time like
i i i was so looking forward to when
they're releasing the video and
i'm glad that it's gotten the responses
that's got i mean
it got a million views i mean i'm
literally [ __ ] myself right now
seeing that the video has over a million
views a million people yeah by the way
by the way what's your what what's your
ig ig
is vaughn so v-o-m yeah and whitmer
w i b is in boy m e r von
whitmer all right cool i put the ig in
the description the video anybody wants
to go check this man out
it's in the description so if you guys
refresh you should be able to see it uh
but
listen man we appreciate appreciated
having you on you were you were
hilarious in that video so thanks so
much for coming on
and uh and then yeah that's that's
pretty much all the questions is there
anything you want to tell everybody
about the video that they may not have
understood or anything like
closing notes that you want to say
closing notes
um
i do have to say like the the dm's that
i've gotten lately are
are so funny with uh i love all the
support that i've been on like i got
guys hitting me up just saying like
oh i loved the video i loved your baby
line
uh oh my gosh all the other people
i love your baby
other people i want to let you know bro
like uh uh oh my gosh
what did he say he said hey us guys that
hate
women need to stick together right and i
was like whoa
whoa yeah
slow your roll here bro like you had me
there for a second
i i love women vagina's the best okay
like i don't want to knock you
you don't want to [ __ ] block yourself
over a youtube video
it's not because you lightly wrote to
someone that you hate the person or you
hate the whole thing and
and it hits the defense um when i
contacted her she had nothing but
positive things to say about she's like
she's a really cool guy got no issues
with him so
um she's yeah she has a very like amico
chemical amicable feelings towards you
in that regards
right i mean it was i thought the whole
thing was very neutral
and uh
anything that she said wasn't i wasn't
all that pertinent it wasn't like
no but it's based on nothing it's just
it's just based on
you know what she sees so there's no
context to whatever for the pictures and
everything and stuff so yeah
people want to interpret it and fit
their own narrative and kind of go with
them
yeah yeah they think you're in your room
crying because you're hurt
yeah i was
chilling the whole time yeah cool man
well listen yo thank you so much for
coming on man we appreciate having you
no yeah this is this is this is a blast
just yeah have fun you guys are awesome
i absolutely love your reaction video
that was
that was the best thing that came out of
it because
like the other ones weren't yeah they
were all right
yeah you know they were ragging on you
calling you trash and they were like oh
my god girl power so
don't worry we get it we brought a bit
of balance to the system you know what
i'm saying we
we saw both sides but we had fun it was
a fun video we all had a good laugh so
at the end of the day that's all that
matters so thanks for coming out brother
of course thank you and preach all right
thank you very much
all right and with that let's go back to
uh yeah so what did you think what did
you think about that conversation chat
it's cool to chat with the people that
we
it's just weird it's weird that we're
able to communicate and have that
the inside and how they really felt and
yeah i'm looking forward to doing more
like that
to be like hey you know what yeah that's
what happened yeah yeah
i agree i liked it he's cool man and he
seems fine and
that's interesting when you watch people
through like an online medium you think
you have an understanding of what's
going on with them or what they're
feeling but
you know most of the time you really
don't know you have no way of knowing so
that's just one of those things i first
want to give a quick shout out to
charles edward she's always our biggest
donor this man coming out with another
five hundo
okay all right and you know what happens
when we do a little five hundo
i put on a little bit of morena you know
what i'm saying just just
hey get him give him that shoulder
guy cloudy
hey let's go
hey all right all right all right all
right
so if you when are you releasing it so
we're actually having to get mastered
right now
we're having it mastered right now i
know they don't that so so yeah
yeah i'm gonna put out a video on the
topic tonight and then we're gonna have
a release date for early this week so
uh yeah people cannot yet you can't find
it
yeah because it's not findable that's
right yeah so charles edward cheese that
one was for you you know i mean gave you
a little little little dance break let's
go
gave you a whole course plus an intro i
got a couple of those all right charles
edward cheese
all right we gave you that dance cheese
all right great content my girl and i
love watching video thanks for all y'all
do appreciate that
all right lord of pond we appreciate you
too okay so uh
who uh lord of parktown
lord of pretty ass white girltown pretty
no pretty ass white girl pogba
it's fat ass white girl pog
fat ass p-h-a-t ass
white girl that's that's a prawn term
for when you're looking up adult videos
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and uh k-11 carbo appreciate the
conversation really shifted my view on
that video very glad to stop by hey man
thank you for
coming on we appreciate that oh no um
someone's going to be who's going to be
the next guest skippy
uh for today we have no other guests
we're going to be uh
james charles dropped an apology video
and i thought it would be good to to to
cover that we don't actually have them
on as a guest i don't know why you
thought we were bringing this man
on yeah i know i'm not doing all that
[ __ ] uh but anyways
um so uh yet another apology video so
we're gonna
be doing that then we're gonna cover
another topic and then we're going to go
to collins all right so if you guys want
to call in
be sure to go to the discord and be
there waiting because we're going to be
bringing in folks soon
all right so james charles
all right oh that's the makeup artist
that's always like being creepy and
for this thing you know trying to
prey on people apparently okay here we
go this is the
this is this is the video itself so let
me just kind of
come in front of you without no makeup
because i come in front of you clean
in a white background because you know
all right so you know listen i don't
know much about this video so i'm gonna
just pop it in
and let's see what this is all about i'm
gonna speed it up because uh
many of you guys know about two years
ago now i was involved with a very
public online scandal in which
some valley youtubers made some very
serious accusations against me and in
the past couple of weeks similar
accusations are being made again and i
think it's very important that i get on
camera and
talk to you guys honestly about what is
going on uh when this first happened
two years ago i uploaded it to my
channel called no more lies and that
video was a very planned video
it focused on receipts and screenshots
and defending myself in the situation
but i want you guys to know that this
video that i've been making today
is going to be nothing like no more lies
okay so this is a big youtuber who
apparently uh i guess
they said he was with some underage boys
some 15 16 year olds or whatever
uh apparently he claimed that they were
lying about their age and that's how it
happened
uh and just for context i think he's
like 21 years old yeah
just some notes in front of me that i
want to make because it's a very very
serious topic
and i'm going to focus um what happened
about the conclusions that i've come to
and most importantly holding myself
accountable for my own actions
first and foremost i need to say sorry i
owe a massive apology to anybody that
i've heard from anybody that i've been
uncomfortable
with reactions and i also want to
samsung to my friend's
desktop audio
i want to see if this helps because
you shouldn't have to and this is really
really embarrassing uh when this all
started online a few weeks ago it
sparked a lot of conversation and many
people have shared their thoughts and
opinions and i want to take some time to
address
literally everything in today's video
but before doing that i want to make it
really really clear that
i fully understand my actions and how
they are wrong uh there's no excuse for
them and i don't plan on making any in
this video either and i hope that you
choose to watch it
all the way through um damn this man
took two minutes to do the whole
preamble go also just want to make a
quick note
that i'm filming this on the night of
march 31st it is currently at 12 50 in
the morning um i'm alone here in
the studio and i know that when i upload
this more it's going to be april fool's
day which is awful timing because this
video and this topic is not a joke in
any way perform uh and i don't want
anybody to think that it is but i also
don't want to wait any longer
[Laughter]
this man this man really upload this on
april fools that's hilarious
i'm not gonna lie that's that's some
beautiful irony uh at least he addressed
it i did not notice until i looked and
i'm like bruh
that's crazy
[Music]
gone
hey man just want to say i want to
never mind nothing about it this is very
very important to me and i'm taking this
very very seriously
the last thing that i want to say before
i just get into it is that i think it's
important that i provide a trigger
warning for
this video uh there's gonna be topics
and things talked about that are very
very sensitive
to some people and i don't want anybody
to have to listen to those if they don't
want to so i'm just letting you know
right now but with all that said i think
it's time that we
talk in case yeah it's been time bro
is this this is inappropriate yes it is
oh wow wow what is wrong with you
but this is not what he looks like is
that
hold on
is this inappropriate yes it is
is this it appropriate
is this inappropriate i don't know oh no
y'all tell me
you're a piece of [ __ ] oh no okay yo
chat tell me put a one in the chat if
you think this is appropriate
okay put a one in the chat if you think
this is inappropriate okay there you go
i don't know to me i don't know i just
that's what i kept thinking about every
time you talk
all right let's just let's just keep
going with the videos
yeah you like [ __ ] for that wow
more recent uh in both of these cases i
had these people on snapchat asked how
old they were right away was told that
they were 18
i believe them engaged in a third
conversation and then later on found
that they were actually 16.
upon finding out i was immediately
embarrassed and blocked both people
later on when i saw them making videos
about it and those videos going viral my
immediate reaction
completely honestly was to be really
really upset i wanted to get on camera
and film another live video where i
gather all my receipts and all my
screenshots and try to tell my side of
the story and then just move on to the
situation
and now looking back that was so stupid
okay 21 year old
talking to people he believes are 18
apparently okay
there's two ways this goes for me okay
and this is just me personally this is
my personal opinion i don't know in
all the details so i'm going gonna just
cover all my bases okay the scenario one
okay scenario one is he's messaging
young folks
okay he's 21 years old famous person
he's messaging young folks okay
and uh they're 18 years old uh but he
actually knows or they're claiming their
team but he actually knows james knows
that they're underage at which point you
know throw the book at him do whatever
you got to do legally blah blah blah
life goes on scenario two okay
scenario two and i think this is what a
lot of people have an issue with okay
is that he's a a 21 year old celebrity
and he's banging his fans and
and how do you feel about it and this is
how i feel if they're legal age
if they're legal if they're above 18 and
they want and they want to bang their
celebrity
i don't care that's me personally that's
their choice they're an adult if they
can go out they can go join a military
they can go fight wars they can take
cars and drive them around take out
loans
i just don't care what adults want to do
with people they admire i don't care if
rich girl you know rich people
want to use their their money influence
to get laid i don't care if powerful
people want to use their money for this
i don't care if beautiful people
want to use their influence to get laid
i just don't care
if they're legal i don't care
if they're illegal do what y'all want to
do and i think that's my uh
i think the problem is that my thoughts
weren't
that's that's the thing some people have
a problem with that and then others have
a problem with
don't ever be banging your fans no
that's yeah same
same same same you know what i mean
because what does that even mean
first off there's no science behind any
of this no one two okay
this take this take i don't like for a
few reasons what if you're dating
somebody and then they become a fan
while you guys are dating are you guys
now not able to date because you have
some kind of power and influence over
them
you know what i mean like there's a
power dynamic that grows i i just i
don't
i don't like the whole power power
dynamic stuff but
you know it was i was what do i care
about
what do i care about in my couple there
was
that's how we met what you mean she got
enrolled in the cadets
i got uh i was already in the kids for
two years so i had a grade i had i was
corporal
when she met me and she was a recruit
right
and we started hanging yes power
dynamics and i look damn good in a
uniform
so what so we should have no that's not
we can't
yeah yeah it's it's just very
it's unrealistic the amount of people
that work that
that that meet in the in the workplace
the amount of people that
have that dynamic where they admire what
you do because they like what you doing
you're good at it
it's just not real it's not it's
it's unrealistic but whatever the
underage thing
i get i do get yeah
yeah the underworld under each thing is
illegal throw the book you know
okay cool whatever we move past that we
agree on yeah
yeah you don't even have to spend time
on that right like if he knows that you
know i mean
we're done we're done we're done
but if they're above age and they're
adults and
that's what you're into you know i mean
you like you're like 19 year olds and
you're 20
and 21 because he's 21 like i don't care
i know
this might be a spicy take or whatever
what do you want me to tell you a 21
year old who
okay again his thing apparently is
underage
cool but a 21 year old going with 18 and
19 year olds like what the [ __ ] do i
care
how is that a weird age gap increasing
how is that a weird age gap you're
you're an encouraging
child you know yeah
right right right right and again this
is another thing where i just don't care
if people want to bang their fans
i don't know man maybe it's because the
age i grew up in but like groupies was
always a thing
you know what i mean musicians and
always will be always will be
don't don't think that this stops in
2021 it never
always will be yeah yo the amount of
people that we had when i was working in
the hotel yeah
yeah group p's was always a thing
although
i got admit when men or groupies that's
creepy
what when men are groupies why is the
group it's just deemed
creepy oh okay like it's deemed creepy
yeah yeah it's acceptable for women but
for a man it's just really
like yeah what are you doing what are
you doing and i mean
okay so someone says abba once said that
if you held a rank
above him you can never be friends
because you can't be friends with your
boss
sure okay what's your point doesn't mean
you can't have conversations with your
boss does it mean that you guys can't
talk
but how is this the same thing hold up
hold up how is this man pulling rank at
what point does a celebrity have control
over your income at what point does a
celebrity have control over any bodily
function in your life
saying you saying a boss shouldn't be
[ __ ]
their employees it's completely
different than saying
okay listen it's completely different
than saying
um a celebrity can't [ __ ] their fans or
a fan can't [ __ ] their celebrities
how is that the same thing it's not it's
not
right and it's mentioning like oh yeah i
appreciate dating a recruit we were the
same age
yeah that's it she just got into the
cadets
yeah yeah yeah i did so yeah yeah i i
honestly i think especially in america
people baby adults so much we talk about
freedoms we talk about being emancipated
we talk about responsibilities
but then as soon as they become adults
we're like well let's coddle you uh we
you shouldn't be able to [ __ ] this
person because they're too powerful you
shouldn't be able to [ __ ] this person
because you have too much
what does that have to do with anything
are you an adult are you not
unless this person is promising you work
unless this person is like holding it
over your head
or doing some here's the thing right i
would argue that it is [ __ ] up to be
like you're not a real fan if you won't
send me nudes
i would argue that's [ __ ] up morally
now do i care about that legally
no morally i would think that's a trash
thing to do on a just more level i think
it's trash if a regular person says
if you want my affection to love you
like whether it's a celebrity or a
regular person
so that's just a people that people
think but when people talk about power
dynamics and they're like well
you know if this person's so really well
known uh and you're not
guys people [ __ ] dudes at local bands
because they're so enamored like who am
i to tell you
who you can or can't handle
they can't do it you know what i mean
like you guys are drawing parallels and
you and you want to be
babied so hard it's crazy to me it's
crazy
america is a weird place i don't take it
very seriously when it comes to consent
and stuff like that because americans
are very strange
they talk about you know independence
and freedom and all this stuff but at
every turn it seems like their children
when it comes to being responsible for
their decisions
nobody's talking listen i i listen right
here okay
this whole thing right here with the
underage stuff we already agree like if
you did underage stuff then yeah
do what you got to do all right we're
not talking about that
oh so so that's my thought process
that's my thought process on this and
you know hold on hold on i want to get
that dot 3d comment
go back up preach was wrong when he
dated his subordinate
the reason is because if he broke up
with her
would have had control i did break up
with her when we i had control over her
brother
15. i was not no i'm just thinking no
she's now we're 15. do we care
it happened no it happened we did but i
was not dealing with it
who cares i'm just saying who cares you
were 15.
i know i don't care am i crazy like
i don't understand this world anymore uh
two fifteen year old so well he was a
cadet as a corporal
it's cadets it's not that deep
it's not that deep it's the scouts with
military march let's be honest
come on now people are making something
out of things she was yeah
i was 15 she was two 16 year olds one
was a corporate what was a cadet this is
so inappropriate i don't care
like calm down people my god you guys
are such puritans you [ __ ] losers man
i couldn't believe that a 15 year old
cadet [ __ ] a 16 year old cadet that
was a cool
it's the cadets it's like i can't even
take the cadets
seriously bro i'm so tired of people
apologizing for things like that might
seem
like holy [ __ ] who cares
oh man people are uh yeah they're out
there
they're out there uh i i don't know i
don't know we did break up
it didn't happen but we were 15. damn it
people were crazy man gee
i was you forget this like [ __ ] but yo
gee dave
yeah i know i know i know i know
but to them is the thing yeah but it's
corporal and subordinate man we're like
the scouts with military march man rough
calm down
rough and 15 year olds and now people
are going on these witch hunts right
they're like they're you know
you know people were like listen again
this whole james charles stuff in the
underrated stuff cool do you think
i'm not mad at that one person was
underage okay but it's just like it's
like
i remember one time there's like a story
about like this this girl who was 18 and
this guy who was 20 and everyone made it
like this big thing because he had like
100 000 subscribers i'm like who cares
are you an adult are you not this is i
can't stand
i can't stand this rhetoric because here
we are
you know the kids who ran over the the
the the carjacking
teenagers they want to charge them as
adults
right okay for what they did so when
you're 15
right you're old enough to understand
when you hurt somebody or what you
create visible advice
but you can't you can't consent to uh
all this stuff
okay how does that make sense like i
don't know why we're charging but people
love to make it like
they talk like it makes sense and then
afterwards
you have a full ass grown 18 year old
okay
who wants to bang a 20 year old who she
admires but no she's too
she can't handle that responsibility
like none of this makes sense to me
that's how i feel about it what are your
thoughts um
it makes no sense like you want to
charge adults
you want to charge kids as adults but
the same kid cannot
it makes no sense but whatever we said
that already yeah
yeah yeah this is this is a non-story
for me but anyways uh we're just moving
on because uh honestly
this whole this whole it just i can't
stand the pureness
of everyone and people are really like
about that oh yeah
yeah it's like glass houses bro it's
like if it's like it's as if
they want to know what is
it's too easy it's too hard to have
to use your common sense you know using
your common sense is a hard thing it's
it's it's you it's
actually a lot of work you have to now
and analyze a lot of things you have to
be able to
you know look at one thing and look at
another situation and every situation
is separate just doing what they're
doing like right now is like oh yes this
and that
guilty yeah it's easy yeah it's so easy
people are lazy and don't want to use
their judgment and don't want to use
their thinking their critical thinking
it takes a lot of energy and it takes a
lot of because
every case is different but no they
don't want to do that they want to bunch
up a bunch of cases and be like no
it's all wrong it's just them yeah
yeah but this is just my thoughts on
that matter i'm not i'm not that
involved in this whole james charles
things
no no nor do i care okay i'm i'm not
that into it
i was just talking about the the
principle right like
we already said it like 20 times if he
was involved with underage folks and he
did it so annoyingly like yeah throw the
book at him like let's just move past
that i'm just talking about a broader
discussion
that's what i was thinking about what
you know you have to think of a stage in
my face man you can remove that [ __ ]
man this is a meme from a hot long time
ago shows hilarious be yourself this is
one of the funniest
memes bro um well yeah well yeah and
even the whole like dave chappelle had a
great bit about this which is how old is
15 really
remember that bit how to work how old is
15 really yeah
great bit which talks about the idea of
like charging you know 14 year olds as
adults in retards to
you know to to crime and stuff like that
which is like
to me i have a law saying that those are
kids
but then at some point you decide no
they're adults i decide that they're at
like it's like yeah yeah yeah but
anyways i don't want to stay on this
topic too long
um i i i yeah i don't want to stay on
this topic too long i just
this is what i've learned to do over
time i just don't listen to
um the american commentary sphere
when it comes to this topic because it's
lacking nuance in such a severe degree
there's very little science to back any
of this stuff you know even the whole
discussion of like you shouldn't [ __ ]
your boss i agree you shouldn't do it
people do it regardless some ladies want
to [ __ ] their boss some men want to [ __ ]
their boss
okay why because the power is alluring
is it inappropriate yes should it be
allowed no but people are doing it
should you [ __ ] your co-workers
no not even but people are doing it and
they don't only do it a little bit they
do it often
why because you're at work from 8 pm 8
a.m to to five p.m and uh
for a lot of people nine to five right
some people spend more time out working
at home
right so so the people you and what you
do you meet people who are around you so
what do people do they bang their
coworkers
so irrespective of how i feel about it
it's not about what i think what are
people doing
that means there's something there just
saying you shouldn't you know
there's something there there's
something that we have to but it's
normal that people are banging
each other like in a work setting i
understand that that happens you spend
so much time together
yeah yeah you spend so much time with
people you guys work in the same field
so you have some of the same stresses
you can confide in each other it stands
to reason that you might find each other
attractive you're there around each
other
all the time it's normal it's just
normal it's normal
so you know it's like is there even a
world where men and women can coexist in
a workspace
and not have any form of intimacy and
even in places where it's super strict
where they have like
anti-fraternization policies they still
do it they still do it it still happens
the number of
army stories that you hear yep come on
now
yeah come on yeah so come on so when
when
are we gonna have an honest discussion
with ourselves stop pretending to be
things that we're not
and also admit to things that we are
right
to the way that we live because it's
great to aspire to these things but it's
clearly not happening in the process
because people are not living to to this
inspired idea that none of us are
subscribing to
in full right we are chastising people
oh you didn't live up to this thing that
not even i can do
you're garbage
so is brazil they're being they're being
whole babies right now
all right so so so i think i think
that's like the main thing that i think
about
him i don't know i don't know it's kind
of fun to just look at his head i'm not
going to friendship
not even a friendship um here's another
topic i want to bring up do you think
that
um people said this and they said to me
they feel like they feel like
trying and dating is corny like if you
put in effort like that's just corny
what do you think yeah
i know i know there's a lot of people
that think that there's a lot of people
that move that way that they're trying
right try no it's going to look like i i
heard that a lot you know somebody goes
yeah but
it's going to look like i'm i'm i'm i
want too much
right like what yeah and maybe it's
because i've been out of the game for so
much that i'm like what do you even mean
yeah
but yeah but if i try if i call him now
if i do this if that
it's going to look like i i try too much
like i want him too much [ __ ] you do
yeah you do that's actually what you
want
right you be talking and rambling about
you want that you you want that guy you
want that guy you want that guy but then
you're gonna
man you know what i don't know if it's
the age thing i'm too old for this [ __ ]
too old for this [ __ ] this game game
i was done back then
carl if you want to call don't call if
you don't feel like calling and that's
that
yeah it's but but yeah people think that
if it it's it looks corny right it
really looks
corny oh yeah people are really against
it they're really against it but i'm not
i'm like yo just do your thing i wanted
to bring this up to you guys right
because
a lot of people are asking me why i was
doing the live dates right and on a
recent video
somebody left a comment they said hey
both of the dates were fun and
uh they all seemed to have fun i'm glad
he's doing these
i'm learning how to talk to women from
this right absolutely
and i was really i was really happy when
that happened why because
one of the big reasons why i do this the
big big one of the big reasons why i do
this
is just so
i don't want to just do this oh hold on
i gotta backtrack i'm not bad right but
i gotta
add something to what i was saying but
you're right there you go
all right there you go so yes um it's
a lot of people don't know like a lot of
young men message me like i don't know
how to talk to women yeah i don't know
how to talk to girls yes right
so i was like man you need to just kind
of i'm like why don't i just show you
guys yeah right so i set up these
interviews i don't know anything about
these ladies
okay like i might other than like a
little bit of their social media i don't
research them i don't do pre-interviews
i just roll a dice and i'm like i'm
gonna do a bunch of
right and i tell them straight up i'm
like uh you know preferably you're gonna
be single and preferably
uh just be comfortable the idea that's
going to be a date because we're going
to be flirting a little bit back and
forth whatever
so i do these talks right and you're
doing great it's fun i watch your
[ __ ] you're doing great
right and there's two things i get
all these are not dates i don't know how
you did personally me they look just
like that
i'm just out there i'm asking a bunch of
questions we're vibing we're laughing
and it's fun that's generally how it
happens
now not every date is like that
sometimes the day is a fail and that's
okay that's part of the process
but generally my advice to young folks
is like guys learn to ask questions
and learn to just take an interest and
be curious about the person in front of
you
your dates might look different me how i
am with you right
how i am when i talk to you is how i am
when i talk to to
the ladies like it's me right and what i
want to encourage young men to do
absolutely is to be themselves in front
of these ladies and be curious
and that's that's what they're going to
find attractive that's what they're
going to get you more than
i don't know what the hell you watching
them prawns and [ __ ] like that but that
that's
that to me that's corny you know what i
mean always everything
revolving everything around sex and then
you forget why you you wonder why [ __ ]
don't work
yeah just don't worry because you don't
know the person after that when you get
when you're getting a person pants or
whatever what not and
you still don't know the person you know
the names but you don't know them you
don't know how they operate how they
function and stuff like that
how is that the the when you do what you
do how you talk to people it would be
how i talk to people
you build much more intimacy than if
you're just talking in that flirty
flirty [ __ ] that we we know that
that to me that is corny you just
revolve things about that
it makes it it puts them out and it puts
an amount of stress
of unwanted stress it's not supposed to
be wanted it's not wanted
it's not what we really want it's not
casual there's always that pressure
if you don't make it as
pressured around sex or whatever whatnot
you get to know the person you go step
by step
you ease it in you chill you relax it
the vibe is
better and after that if you get you
know inside them panties or you let them
in or whatever what not whatever
happened happens you know you do the
grown-ups
there's a connection that is beyond yeah
you know what i'm going to do to you
that [ __ ] that that corny [ __ ] you got
another
connection yeah and that's that yeah i
would talk to someone like that
that's that's what i do in those videos
is exactly what i've been doing on my
business
now i don't do these to pick up ladies
none of these women are women i'm going
to see ever again or talk to what i
might like chit chat with it but i'm
never going to meet them in person
i do this right so that young dudes who
are like trying to get in the game one
like what does it mean when someone says
be yourself
that's what it looks like what does it
mean when someone says
yo man ask questions learn to be
inquisitive that's what it looks like
i'm just asking i'm curious about the
person
i'm genuinely interested i'm not forcing
it and if it doesn't work and there's no
chemistry that's okay that happens too
right one of the dates there wasn't that
much chemistry that's fine
but there is some effort you have to put
in there is some learning that you have
to do
you know when i got started in this like
i didn't know what i was doing
do you think i knew what i was doing
when i first i was looking for resources
everywhere i was doing all that stuff so
there is some measure of trying that you
should have to do whether it's getting
in decent shape putting on some decent
clothes getting
proper perfume like yo there's things
that you need to do you need to make an
effort it's not corny
to want to learn these things a lot of
people need to humble themselves
and to admit that they don't know how to
flirt they don't have any game
and they don't know how to seduce i'll
be honest with you the difference
between a woman who has sex appeal knows
how to do seduce but and the woman who
does it is night and day
and i'll also be honest with you vast
majority of women
to have zero idea how to seduce a man or
how to
how to have sex appeal you can be sexy
you can be attractive
sex appeal is a completely different
thing and i feel like a lot of times
ladies
don't want to put effort to anything
other than like the looks in that
regards when it comes to the mating
strategy so
um i don't know how to give you ladies
that i can't count you on that i can't
help you
but for the dudes i learned from other
people right i watched resources so if i
can do anything that helps you out then
i'm happy with that
that's pretty much most of my life i
agree i agree
if the trying too hard what what is
corny what i don't like me trying too
hard when you look
there's a difference between trying too
hard and being
needy and looking meanie
that is another side of the thing where
you look like you're really needy that's
something
else that is some other uh other stuff
that's why not we're trying
that's not what we're talking about but
just you you're caring for that person
yeah so how was your
how was your day when you started off
and be like you know when you had a
conversation with the
and just like so you we do this thing
how was your day i was digging that
yeah but that's a conversation but
that's how we started the video
i i literally look i didn't so people
think i have type i don't prepare
questions i don't have like icebreaker
questions when i went in i'm like yo you
know what i thought was most funny
i hit you up with this whole paragraph
and you were just like hold up
how is it i thought that was hilarious
i'm like let's just go in on that
but it is right and so that started the
conversation on a high note because i'm
like
that's an interesting thing i could feed
off the just the fact that you
stopped me and you're like but how are
you
i thought that was i'm like where did
that come from manners right
right right right and it just started
the interview and even the second one
the second one was great she was pushing
back asking me a bunch of questions and
we
how did we start the second one the
second one i came in i'm like yo i heard
french people stink
just some prejudice yeah and then we
just went from there so
you know hopefully there's stuff that
you guys can pick up on
and enjoy uh but at the end these are
just things that you guys can use as
resources even if it's not useful for
you
it might be useful for other guys right
there's a lot of dudes
um there's a lot of dudes who don't know
and they message me all the time so i'm
hoping this
this helps people but yeah that's pretty
much the gist of it
yeah but everyone's like oh my god
that's an interview that's that's how i
date
that's how i do my dates and you know
what when i'm asking all those questions
women love that yeah because they love
you interested they're more into you
than if you try to buy do they bite your
lip in years so
yep would you like to do when that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] boy [ __ ]
yep interest yo so what do you actually
do what is it oh
dope that's all right and you see how
like whatever
whatever also when you say a woman and
you you you have
there's also pre um yeah
prejudice about what she's saying his
face is not changed or whatever would
you when you might
oh you're a stripper you just go okay
cool what was that lie
you're not gonna be like oh word yeah so
you get damn beans
does bears make you dance yeah do you
ask whack that's right that's mad corny
all right cool
yeah move on that looks if you look at
her perspective
it's not gonna it's not gonna be it's
not gonna be appealing oh
word so you're gonna strip for me later
nah that's not
swag a complaint that a lot of ladies
have
when like i'll be on dates i'm like yes
why didn't that last date work out
one thing that women will often say and
ladies if you're in the chat you could
put a one if you know what i'm talking
about
guys they'll be like yeah a lot of guys
sometimes they just come on dates and
they just want to talk about themselves
but they weren't curious about me now
ladies you can let me know have you guys
had that happen to you where you've been
on dates and guys seemed more interested
in themselves and didn't show genuine
interest in you
now if you leave a date this is why i
ask a lot of questions and i'm very
intrigued by people
one i'm curious so i do want to know a
lot of things but two
whenever you leave a date and if the
girl goes oh he's a bit mysterious or oh
you know
if she says you are mysterious because
like she felt like you asked her a lot
of questions
you're off to a fantastic start i said
that already
right man i said it before i said that
if my girl comes back home
if my girl comes back home and she's
like yeah i'm like how was your day and
she's like oh yeah there's a new guy at
work and i'm like yeah how is he and she
says
well he's mysterious i'm [ __ ] yup
there's nothing i can do
all right it's done so look at look at
the chat look it up look at all the ones
you know
how many times have these ladies been on
dates and they felt like a dude was not
interested in them
so when all you guys are sitting there
like oh my god is this an
interview yeah if you [ __ ] goobers
knew how to ask people questions
and take an interest in who the person
in front of you is you wouldn't think
what i'm doing in the interview what i'm
just doing is the right way to do dates
bro
but but you you you you do you you do
you you do you
you do you you do you okay all right i i
don't take advice from randoms
in the chat generally so what kind of
painting is you with
yeah so there you go the chat lets you
know what's up uh but i'm gonna go a
couple super chats and then we'll do
some call-ins
all right fred the truth says uh the
lies i appreciate it sammy a
i have the biggest crush on ab all the
way from australia hey we appreciate my
aussie people
uh we already read that lloyd
frederickson thank you for the dono
uh fred the truth thank you for again
wren taylor carolyn watson appreciate
the five donald guys we'd like you
clerica
ah say it again americans are just
babies some of them are yo
listen i love my american brothers and
sisters like when i lived there i really
enjoyed my time there i actually love
the american people when i'm down there
but the way that they dominate the
commentary
on a social level and the way that they
sometimes
the way a lot of foreigners sometimes
allow the american
rhetoric to dominate their own cultural
conversations is
i'm not a big fan of because while i
love america a lot of their ideas some
of them are trash in my opinion
bree says i'm american i gotta admit we
are less involved in other countries hey
we appreciate that
uh ron red thank you for the five dollar
dono
ki ayala common sense is not so common
we agree
lord of pog town thanks again o'shea
leonix
justin smith the real problem is the
fact that this issue is handled
differently based on offenders gender
and orientation
also for targeted straight males flip
that dynamic and see what happens
yeah hessing hyssops thank you for the
donor
lord reality aj taylor and john rossi
appreciate the the don't know
okay who's scooters entertainment thank
you oh man he came in twice with two
donors thank you all for the live dates
and you showing how to talk and attract
ladies because y'all said in another
video when it comes to man we wasn't
taught
it growing up by the right people i had
my dad and uncles and they didn't teach
me
they just tell not to teach by saying
it's not hard
yeah they always say it's not hard
that's just emotion
ain't hard that's just y'all go out
there and do your thing that's just
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's right
yeah that's that [ __ ]
all right go out there all right so um
so let's bring in some collars if you
guys are already
uh waiting let's just uh bring some
folks in all right let's uh
here we go we're gonna go with the first
person here
all right so we got aaliyah in the
building ali are you there
oh yeah i'm here well i just did not
expect you guys to uh
pop in i was watching you eyes hold up
let me let me just
let me just do this real quick would you
say that again
no i was saying i was watching the live
video on youtube while you guys
called me in so i was like okay excuse
me okay
no no no so uh yes what was it what was
your uh
what was the thing that you wanted
situation okay i'm gonna make a long
story short
please basically yeah no i already know
i'm not gonna give you guys a ted talk
sorry about that
no worries no worries so uh basically my
situation is i've been friends with this
person since high school it's a friend
of mine
and basically um
a couple years went by i was in a rough
spot they let me stay with them
i was able to get back on my feet get my
own place
and during that summer of all of this
happening
um i basically they invited me to come
to a
like a barbecue right so anyways long
story short
i was in a relationship with a trash
person at the time that none of my
friends was agreeing with you know
early 20s it is what it is um
and basic pardon scene okay so so so
so yeah so so let's get to the end what
happened so basically when i was at this
barbecue um the people that she invited
did not
like my man at the time and
um they were just acting really shady
there was a point where literally
she ended up leaving with everyone that
she invited except me and my
significant other at the time they all
just left
it was just weird like it was extremely
weird so i ended up leaving the house
because i thought it was super weird
and we never really spoke since so
anyways
you know the pandemic happened it had me
thinking about life and my friendships
and i was like you know what i respected
that girl overall besides that situation
are you trying to reach out partying you
try to reach out
yeah so i tried to reach out we made you
know we made amends
or whatever right so anyways i for why
she reacted that way in a situation
because i thought it was kind of petty
or whatever
the reason that y'all act that way
all right you get all the real things
you know
right exactly i forgot to give you the
real t
the reason why they blocked you off and
they leave you is because they don't
like they're not like command them
you hear the man that i like they don't
want to be with him so you
me you go away go away we don't like you
you're here
so what happened is that they didn't
want to mess with the dude so they had
to
you know what we not about that dude he
toxic but she's gonna be with him if it
weren't invite her
she cannot not invite him so let's just
dip exactly
that's what i thought it was but she
actually ended up disclosing to me
that um the reason she kind of wanted to
part ways at the time
was because of the fact that i was
friends with somebody
that i ended up disclosing to her did
not like her
because of the fact that their best
friend is a guy it's a guy basically
oh that was also that but also the
reason
why the dip was really because of your
boyfriend listen listen if someone's not
going to be a friend with you because
you're friends with somebody that
doesn't like them
uh-huh who cares y'all that's what i
said i was just like what happened i'm
gonna just say you might need some
better friends
but the gag is is that she
basically she met one of
she met a friend of mine through this
okay all right
it's getting too complicated honestly a
lot of these minor details is not
necessary
if your friend wants to stop hanging
around you because you're friends with
somebody that does not like them
they're a shitty ass friend okay unless
that person extorted them unless that
person violently hit them or some other
[ __ ] like that
okay it's not that it's not that deep so
i think you might need better friends in
my opinion if my friends ever came to me
but bro you friends with this person
i'm like yeah like well they don't like
me i'm like so [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean so so that's
what i would tell you get
get some better friends in my opinion
what would you say i said you said what
you said i said what i said
oh all right that'd be my opinion so so
best of luck to you guys y'all are the
best thanks for having me out i
appreciate
it no problem chase all right we're
gonna bring in the next person
okay guys i don't know that's such a
petty reason this is why
i had that conversation with you oh you
gonna chill with him
go ahead go in there oh you gonna chill
with him yeah
then we not chilling then no just don't
bring that [ __ ] around
right we we don't we yeah
you don't need to be around me but you
know what i mean
you're a grown-ass person chill with
that [ __ ] that's it it's like
it's not that deep
this is why i don't listen to people
when it comes to like their their their
definitions of friendship i'm like i
don't like what most people define as
friends
so why am i going to listen to y'all
about how who and what
what i should call a friend look at that
that's
that's petty that's betty as [ __ ] that's
pain i don't like that person so you
can't be friends with them
who are you is that what you call a
friend
my mom didn't like some of my friends i
was so chilling with my friends
who are you what the hell you think you
are
i don't like your little friend well you
don't know my little friend yeah
you don't know them you just thought of
me like i don't like what he wears or
whatever what not
stop it knock it off and guys when you
say to make a long story short then you
speak for 30 minutes
that's a long long long long long long
story trying to be made sure make a
short story long
all right all right all right you're up
next brother much love
okay what's up oh yes sir so mr nasar
what's up
what did you want to talk about today uh
well first i want to start with
the french do smell that's why they make
all the cologne in the perfume
i'm just putting that out there all
right second of all
hold up cologne is in germany
yeah but it's all the toilet it's the
french thing okay but
you said cologne but it's really older
toilet okay oh the toilet is from france
it was the more that taught
the french people how to bathe yeah
because the arabs came down
and they were like all you dirty arabs
and like you smelly
he got to drop a little bit that
knowledge be like actually the europeans
were the dirty ones
i mean if you ask us you know yeah yeah
we know it is so so what do you want to
talk about today
uh well uh i i want to talk about uh
right now i'm 20. uh i live in beirut
lebanon
right uh oh yo how did i know this man
was lebanese bro normal i [ __ ] could
smell it
it smells like cologne all right keegan
yeah
yeah the colonizers left a little too
much of that back here
yeah yeah so
i'm 20. i've been single for a little
over a year now
and i'm starting to think i i've noticed
that i have this
i feel compelled to be in a relationship
right
and i i've been reflecting on it and i
feel
that it's more a fear of death or being
left behind especially given the
situation of the country itself
uh even though i would say
to put it lightly i i don't think i've
had a very good any
very good relationships in the past so i
i did want to ask
well how do you there is a pressure
i i i think there is definitely a delta
between when you
like a time where it's okay if you're
not a relationship or whatnot and
maybe not in my stage just yet but later
on in your life if you're not in a
relationship
society does put that pressure on you
like oh you gotta get married you gotta
you know start a family or something so
i i just wanna ask i'm not
there yet but i would i am interested in
how
and what you think of that
sorry so so what's your question
yeah sorry uh so just briefly
what's your question uh so if you were
to look at
at what point do you think it's time to
be released down yeah settle down and be
in a relationship take it away oh that's
an easy one
whenever the [ __ ] you ready
that's it if you're not ready you're not
ready and guess what you might never be
ready
it's a possibility okay so you you might
not
whenever you're ready not when other
people sell you when you're ready
at your 23 you should be in a
relationship now that'll mean [ __ ]
oh you've been going out with her for
five years you should be in the re you
should be married now
i don't mean [ __ ] it's none of your
business y'all know
when you're ready when you are ready
when you feel like hey you know what
yeah i could do this
you do it if you're not you're not
if at some point it's causing you
problems you're not ready at some point
you're like
i think i should be ready then ask your
quest ask you questions
why ask yourself some questions why you
are not ready why what
just you are allowed to ask you a bunch
of questions am i ready
am i ready now why am i not ready what
does it need for me to be ready
what should what do i have to achieve to
be ready
what is that's what it is that's what
you don't ask people they don't know
they're not in your head and they're not
going to be the ones in the relationship
don't rush things what can people always
tend to
make you rush things but they don't know
they're not in your room in your
situation and
they're not in your head they're not in
your predicament you should know but ask
yourself a bunch of questions
what are you saying abba um you live in
lebanon lebanon is like a mixture of
like very progressive people and like
very
uh culturally conservative people which
side of the aisle do you land on
i'd say i'm more on the liberal ends i'm
you know half american so
i'm recognizing that yeah i i felt like
that i felt like that
if that's the values then i would argue
that preacher's answer is probably
correct
um it really comes down to to to what
you
look at relationships as and like you
know what responsibilities if i if you
had like more conservative values i
would tell you probably getting married
and having kids young is probably your
best bet
you don't because no escape that's your
you know but it's just like it comes
down to what your value system is and if
if
you have those and yeah he's right
you're young be patient be patient
all right i also if if it's not too much
of a
bother there's also a sub question to
that about um
i can't we can't take sub questions
because there's so many people waiting
so we gotta
as much as i hate to cut it off and how
cool you are i gotta just take one all
right
yeah no worries all right thank you for
coming out cheers
cheers yeah i can't take two man
all right next person we got korea and
if
you have those and yeah that's right all
right okay hold up hold up
just uh turn off the stream and then
we'll unmeet you yeah
all right cool ready okay all right
right now yeah yeah yeah for sure so
what did you what do you want to talk
about
uh i want to talk about
the aspect of
in starting up relationships
uh i tended to be
more um closed more
secretive not secretive but more so uh
like how you mentioned that
mysterious uh girl mysterious
sure yeah girls would want to um
know more about me but uh the
thing i felt most hindered my
ability to uh get
uh into serious relationships
more recently and to specify it
uh was that uh girls were like oh you're
you're
cool but what else can you uh
provide what what else can you tell me
about yourself
but uh in
where i live it's kind of conservative
and i cannot like girls are not that
outgoing in asking questions to guys
uh so i'm left here just
being mysterious hanging around with
girls sorry
i'm i'm just i'm just gonna ask so you
feel like you're too
mysterious okay yeah yeah and people
never ask you questions and so that's
why you're not
yeah i feel like i can't express myself
i can't have this uh
i can't share things with people why not
um what do you want to share with people
do you want do you like butt plugs like
what's wrong that you can share i mean
share
intimacy is the worst
why you said they're conservative but i
don't know a place on this planet where
a man being intimate with a woman is
seen as a bad thing
so i don't understand uh maybe i okay i
phrased it wrong
uh i mean uh the
reason i mentioned the concerto
conservative part was
uh women are not that outgoing here
so they just never asked questions about
uh anything too i mean i'm kind of
generalizing here i know but
so so what do you do when they talk to
you they don't talk they don't ask any
questions to you they just stand there
and and they stare at you no no i mean
we conversate
uh there there's like conversation
happening but
i don't know i get on my act uh i'm like
acting all mysteriously but i can't
i can't i can't feel like i can finalize
things and get to have a uh
serious relationship with them what i'm
gonna say is like
if someone's into you generally they're
gonna ask you a few questions at some
point okay maybe not initially maybe
take some time but
someone's really interested in you
they're going to ask you questions i
don't know how else to put that so
um how old are you i'm 18.
you know what man you're 18 bro just be
patient this
man i was taking this whole thing
seriously like this man has done a lot
this man you're 18 bro
just keep dating i mean uh
trust me just keep dating okay go on
real dates you know show some real
interest all right say like yo
i'm interested i want to go on they
don't ask you questions you date where
you are from
yeah we can date i mean uh i used to
speed
like speed date a lot in uh high school
yeah okay all right all right bro listen
first off we're showing
you talking to 18 ruff ruff i'm gonna
just tell you this okay you're 18.
don't stress it be patient you're 18.
you've just hit adulthood
okay just brown's taking this whole
thing seriously like
bro yeah hey man you listen you got this
all right believe in yourself you sound
like you're already doing good so just
keep going okay there's no way you're
gonna fail
all right unless you look like [ __ ]
smeagol from lord of the rings i think
you'll be fine
okay thank you all right peace this man
said 18 bro
he he out here talk about i was speed
dating in high school [ __ ] what
how are you already speed dating in high
school you're talking about
conservatives [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right but
anyways let's let's go to the next
person
boom all right yeah if you can just uh
bring your cameras on
okay and if you can also just turn off
the stream
so yeah if you please use it please use
the cameras that's why all right
all right so what's your question hey so
uh
i've been in the innovation with my
girlfriend for late sorry
so so just uh if you can use the cameras
and
and repeat that uh i've been with my
girlfriend
can you hear me right i have the mask on
like can you even
yeah i i can hear you i can hear you we
just can't see you
yeah i thought it was you all right you
got me all right yeah we got you uh i've
been in relation with my girlfriend for
like four months now
and like i feel like i feel like
everything is going cool like i just i
feel like we don't talk much
and like we we like hang out like a lot
like we hang out like like
pretty much every day like she comes
over a lot but we just i feel like
when we when we do like hang out it's
mostly like
i wouldn't say like our relationship is
built off mostly off like lust or
anything like i feel like
like we mostly like like recording
everything we just like
we just don't do like much like talking
and i just and even when we go out like
like if we go out to like lunch or
something it's like
we eat and it's like okay cool that food
was good this is a nice place like
i feel like there's not a lot of like
interesting topics you know i mean
you ain't got much to talk about facts
like it feels like
there's just like i know i i'm not even
trying to diss you some [ __ ]
i'm talking about me when i was 20 i
ain't got much to talk about
i mean i was a dancer so i was dancing
uh track and field yeah i just i wasn't
like big in the extracurricular so i
feel like i'm not like
i'm not like a boring person but like i
just don't i just don't be like
i'll be trying to like i go to work all
the time i'm just trying to y'all
started dating during this pandemic
uh yeah okay and y'all can't do
activities i'm assuming because of where
you live
i mean it's it's are you indoors why you
got your mask on when you're indoors
you're just trying to like hide your
faces
yeah yeah i mean it's cool if like
that's fine it's fine i i was just
worried
i was like i don't know what kind of
regulations girlfriend not not
[ __ ] oh okay uh okay
okay my bad i didn't know that that's my
bad that's not me all right i'm gonna
apologize to you bro
um y'all started meeting this pandemic
and you guys can't go on super
interesting dates correct
okay so let's just dive down a bit so
like we could go out to eat and all that
but like
we haven't been like theaters and
nothing like that okay how about when
you guys are just
chilling together and you guys are in
the same space do you feel good are you
guys just like do you like being around
her
yeah i would say like like she uh we're
we're like similar and i like
really like her energy or whatever so i
feel like in in the matter that we're
similar like she also like just doesn't
talk much like we
i feel like she like she's like just
like shy and like i feel that too
because i'm like a shy person
so so i'm gonna just say one last scene
you just have to ask yourself
do you feel the need to do all these
extra conversation is because
you want that or is it because you feel
like supposed to relationships are
supposed to be like that
okay there's a difference between the
two there's a difference between the two
all right because sometimes we come in
with ideas of what relationship is
supposed to look like
okay and then we get something else and
we're like wait it doesn't match this
idea something's wrong something's not
necessarily wrong
you just came in with expectations that
aren't matching feelings
if you look forward to seeing her if you
like being in the same space as her
i think you're already off to a great
start you feel what i'm saying yeah
so so don't get too caught up in your
head as long as you
like the person that you're with and you
enjoy being around that person
then you've got a strong basis for
everything else
all right all right thanks man i
appreciate you something else
one more thing if you got a girl that is
shy and doesn't want to talk
enjoy that yeah cause i was remembering
like you your uh advice was uh shut the
[ __ ] up
if you both of you don't talk enjoy each
other not
talking that's some great you don't have
to talk all the time
sometimes you dare i don't i don't know
who had this wonderful skit it's like yo
like i think it was patrice o'neill we
want you
there but we don't want you there there
yeah we
could you just be around what you're
doing
what is that do you want to do you want
to put chill go go look at
the relationship thing the relationship
skit
of of patrice o'neill that's what it is
she's there
you guys are feeling good enjoy each
other's present you don't have to talk
all the time
yeah yeah so that that that would that
would be uh that'd be our advice pen
thanks for coming on all right all right
loyal videos thanks
all right peace i remember sometimes i
was just chilling with my girl and there
was nothing that was happening
yeah because now we like just
that yeah you know that's always an
interesting oops
that's always an interesting thing
because um i've seen so many
relationships
ruined because people have these
preconceived
ideas of what it's supposed to be and
i'm like
are you good you're trying to am i good
then this is not a thing no that's not
stop making a thing out of something
that is not a thing
if you're making that's the thing you're
making things that are something that
are made that are that are not a thing
you're breaking uh [ __ ] i gotta i gotta
change i gotta change the screen on this
iphone is it broken
no then you might break something else
in the process
yo i mean i'm very low low person like
i'm chilling
so sometimes i'll just be with somebody
and we just relax and i'm not even
saying nothing like
are you mad at me no
well then why aren't we talking i'm just
chilling i like being around you like
i really like to i really like to
not say [ __ ] when i got [ __ ] to say
why you're not talking because i ain't
got [ __ ] to say
my job is to say [ __ ] okay let's
say okay this is my mark of like a good
relationship i enjoy
if i can be around you in silence
and you make the silence better
[ __ ] please stay
because i ain't got time to be talking
all day sometimes i just want to spend a
meal with you
and chill out sometimes you might be
doing some work and i might be doing
some work but we in the same area
feels great that's fantastic
people have all these i want to have
stimulating conversations about
this you know okay that sounds like a
lot and you sound like you go annoying
me on some days
so you go look for that somewhere else
that's me the thing
we can have conversation in great
conversation but it can't be
that a hundred percent of the time yep i
like to have a
meal with my girl we can't eat all the
time
you know what i mean it's a balance of
things and sometimes it's just
we watching [ __ ] we're right there but
with each other presents
there's a tv playing we both on our
phones it's not always like that
that's not the base of the relationship
but that's what's going on
we just chilling on the couch not doing
[ __ ]
yep and that's that that's great yep
selena gallardo thank you for the don't
know john rosie appreciate
uh k roxanne thank you ladies y'all my
big brothers i mean i wouldn't go that
far but i appreciate y'all
third john that sounds eastern european
uh miss watson thank you dark rengi
appreciate the dono inkoshi inanti
mimani all right
oh south africa value value from south
africa
i appreciate you brother all right there
john de roche okay he's back again
brain shark usa has a precedent to
charge minors as adults certain
circumstances
yeah yeah i'm gonna have a discussion
with destiny about this topic so uh
be on the lookout for that uh deadly
thrust don't let the necessity to be in
a relationship define you
great justin carrickton thank you
youtube mods or virgins
donald harry appreciate the donation all
right let's keep going guys let's bring
some more people on
all right let's see here so yeah if you
guys are in
the um queue waiting uh we're only going
to bring people
because we have some trolls who roll by
so it's only gonna be people who have
their cams on all right
so uh lunchism [ __ ] hey man welcome
thank you for coming on the stream if
you want to just turn your camera on and
then go yeah i can turn it on yeah i
wasn't expecting to get in so quickly oh
no worries all right let me just switch
it
yes go ahead so what's what's what's the
chit chat you want to have
now so the problem is you know i can get
i can go to a bar right
get a girl interesting then like we
exchange contacts and then like
after that's when i [ __ ] up if you get
what i mean okay how do you [ __ ] up
do you guys go on dates no that's a
problem i don't
okay all right all right all right we're
going we're gonna just start there okay
so you got the number at the location
right you saw her in person you're like
hey what up ma
you got her number then when you started
texting her was she responding
yeah uh i mean where i'm from we usually
use snapchat and all the texts but still
it works okay so was it
so i'm gonna ask the second question was
it enthusiastic or was it one word
answers
did you so so when i'm leaning on
conversation like this
who's putting in more of the effort as
the conversation goes on is it you or is
it her
i'd say it was a equal effort like um
as in like you know i'd send something
they'd respond like they actually like
look at what the picture was and respond
to what's in the picture if you know
what i mean and then like
okay so what happens when you say you
want to go on a date
i don't know if i have the balls to do
that actually uh i guess that's where i
[ __ ] up
don't i don't try to get to the uh
physical
part i don't understand you you don't
ask them you don't ask them on dates at
some points
i feel like it just it fizzles out the
conversation
or the conversation fizzles out and then
you never get to ask them yeah
the conversation fizzles out okay so if
the conversation's fizzling out clearly
one person is more interested in the
other because i'm assuming you don't
want it to fizzle out
yeah okay so that means that she you're
more interested than the other person
that's what that means
you understand that right yeah okay
two things happen i'm gonna tell you two
these are my two advices to you okay
one i you need to be a better gauge of
when someone's really interested in you
because clearly there's a disconnect
between how you perceive the dynamic and
what's happening
and two i need you to go from snapchat
to a real date asap
okay you get that number you're not
supposed to be out here chatting with
these ladies online they want to know
you about that action boss
how long does it take for you for the
discussion to fizzle out
a couple of days that's what he said
that's too long bro i'll tell you this
bro i get a number from the girl right
right i get her number i text her the
next day i say hey how was you doing i
enjoyed seeing you last night they're
like cool me too blah blah we'll chop it
up maybe
five messages back and forth at most and
i'm like listen
i'd love to see you sometime this week
you down to get together why i'ma tell
you
she already said she was interested when
she gave you the number so if she really
down to go on a date she already agreed
there's expectations if you ask someone
for a number
they're gonna expect you well you ask
for the numbers so
and then if you don't well then all
right
well this is weird i mean i gave him my
number and four days in
nothing all right well deuces yeah
so you got you got to escalate okay this
is the same thing for tinder this is for
everything
because the more time you spend doing
these messages like when you when you
texting
bro it's hard to make your charm come
across it's hard to make
your body language and your intonation
and your presence come across
meanwhile there's other dudes who are
texting her who are like yo when are you
trying to link up
so while you're taking too much time
someone else might be sliding right in
so strike while the iron's hot you came
up you have the courage to approach her
you did your work congratulations
you got her number fantastic y'all going
back and forth great
escalate boom escalate get to that first
date as fast as possible you don't have
to be like come on a date tomorrow
but agree to the date and then let it go
okay all right and then go through this
process a few times you're gonna fail
some girls are gonna flake on dates some
girls can give you their number they're
not gonna be interested
a lot of things are gonna happen but
repeat this
escalate and you're gonna have your best
opportunities for success
okay all right
okay just yeah thanks for the advice
then all right man no problem thanks for
coming on man best luck to you
thanks all right and that's exactly what
i was thinking i was like what were you
thinking
well i was thinking that i'm like yo you
think i'm not gonna think if
you ask for the number there's
expectations [ __ ] gonna expect
you to
okay you ask me my number for what yo um
we need to thought all right cool and
then you get there and like hey how's
your day
no you asked you asked to talk to me
what are we talking about eventually
okay well you ain't got nothing to say
well you know uh buy it
yeah and in case you guys think i'm just
chopping it up and i'm chatting [ __ ] i
promise you ladies who are in the chat
how many times does a dude ask for your
number this [ __ ] texting you for
too long at some point like [ __ ] ask me
out on a date
ladies put one in the chat if you've
been through that experience with a
[ __ ] just be out here talking
for no reason and he not pushing things
forward
doesn't that annoy the [ __ ] out of you
express yourselves my latest watch watch
the ones
watch the ones the ones that come in the
ones are coming they're going to come
flowing in because
they want you to keep it moving man
i've been on tinder days with girls
before and they're like i'm like
so so what made you really want to come
on date she's like man i just like the
fact that you escalated two
[ __ ] are like
in my inbox just mix and after a while
it gets boring like you were just
forward you know i'm like you know what
i'm gonna do it i was like hell yeah
let's go nick
stop playing with me the way you come in
listen stop playing with me all right
all right let's see
there's quite a lot of people in here
okay cool let's just go with the first
person here
we got another aaliyah they want you to
keep it moving
all right are we just gonna have you ask
you to turn off the stream okay
and if you can alia just turn on that
cam
turn on that cam all right we go can you
see me
yes ma'am we can see you how are you
doing sister you
good good all right so leah what's up
what's your question for today
so my question today is pretty much how
do i get back
in like the dating scene of things so
i'm 24 i just finished um getting my
nursing degree and stuff
congratulations book is like so hard on
doing schooling
i feel like i got really behind on like
the dating scene
i live in the bible belt and i'm like
pretty open to dating like outside my
race and stuff
so i feel like because of that i might
have like a harder time
just getting out there in a sense
okay cool preach what you got for her
since you were also raised in a bible
yeah but i got out of that belt my pants
are looser than the [ __ ]
yeah yeah so you got another boy um how
to get back into dating you just have to
basically do it
go go at it get online you know things
are more online i don't know how to
covet situation is where you at but
yeah go online do you have to start to
meet up some people you know i mean you
you have to do it start to do it meet
people at work you can meet people at
work you can meet you know be open
you have to get out there and you know
start start dating what would you have
to say since you're in the dating world
yeah are you are you on any dating apps
um i'm on tinder but i get a lot of [ __ ]
boys
that's definitely going to happen it's
definitely going to happen for sure
um i'm going to say this you're also
coming in at a weird time obviously with
the pandemic it's uh
sliding into dating is a little bit more
difficult right um
but i think once dating once one's
dating once the pandemic
ends you'll definitely want to maybe
take up some social activities that'll
kind of facilitate that
um you know me i'm a big proponent for
for partner dancing i think that's
always a great thing because there's
social events you meet people
kind of naturally you get a vibe for it
um
but yeah as far as like getting back in
the dating scene it's really just
putting yourself out there so it's
jumping on the dating apps whether it's
tinder hinge or whatever people are
using
um and it's kind of just like presenting
yourself like yo i'm actively out there
and then also just engaging in
activities um that might give you
opportunities for social interaction
those are the two things that you can do
to be serious about dating so that means
that you'll still have your work
but on your time off you just put a
little bit of time aside to do to do
that you know
yeah all right thank you and be patient
with yourself it'll it'll come all right
yeah i feel like i'm like in a rush
because like all my friends are getting
married and having kids and stuff and
like i don't want that to like i'm 30
yeah all the time i mean
you'll get to it there you know some of
your friends might rush into a little
bit sooner don't don't don't let that
you know uh dissuade you all right don't
rush all right thanks for coming on
cheers all right yeah
that was uh dull rush let's bring in
somebody else
pretty straightforward
all right we got millie in the building
if you want to just uh turn on that
camera and get it popping
milly millie please
millie can she hear me yeah she gave me
did i get it
all right yeah you got it hey what up
millie hey
good how are y'all i'm good i'm good so
uh what's up
okay so um i'm
pretty i would say i would say i'm
pretty self-aware
so i know that like i'm [ __ ] when it
comes to
online dating i'm 27.
uh yeah and i just have like i like my
biggest problem is just like navigating
i'm i'm [ __ ] at communicating like
throughout
like get me in person i'm really good or
even get me on video chat i'm good but
like
texting i just just
so so so so so i don't understand what
what what problem are you having
uh i guess just like actually like
more i guess like like having continuous
conversation
online or even just like that connecting
because i already have a hard time
connecting with people like um
like in person like with sharing stuff
but
like specifically when it comes to
because like right now that's the only
option
uh with covet and everything is to
actually go online
um but yeah so
so so so you you suck at doing the
online stuff
so why can't you just go on dates i
don't understand like if you're talking
to someone
what's so difficult like if you match
with somebody on tinder okay
and they're like hey i thought you were
cute thinking that cool
did you does it just die there or do you
guys ever go to dates i don't understand
uh okay okay let me ask
a specific question then um like
i guess like for me like the hardest
part would be to actually
because i'm i'm really like uh
i guess this is not that great but i i
put everything into like
my work and like my school and
everything that i do so
i'm kind of like very like i need to
like make sure that if i'm gonna
invest time in you that like i know it's
gonna be like worth my while and i'm not
like and i'm just talking about like you
know the attention and like the time and
all that
so for me it's just like really kind of
knowing okay okay all right i think i
know where this is going you wanna you
suck at
talking to people if they're not in
person
and you wanna know of a way where you
while you suck at talking to people
online or on your phone how can you weed
out people who are gonna waste your time
and then pick the right ones are going
to be worth it considering you have so
little time
is that correct yeah and then like on
top of that when i do
meet someone like they kind of like
which i guess is like my fault i need to
like figure out balance but
like when it comes to them like if
they're feeling me out which is what
usually happens and like i can't message
them
back right away and like i can't like
have a continuous like conversation
through tests because i'm busy
um it's like and and they're always like
oh i like a woman with ambition or i
like
you know i i like that you have like
things that you're doing but then like
in reality it's like
you know i'm busy so i haven't messaged
you and then they're like uh i don't
know
which i understand okay okay all right
preach what do you think
i'm not really sure i understand
basically basically she
so what she's saying is that when she
meets people in person they're like yeah
i like ambitious women but she's saying
i'm so ambitious and i'm so busy i can't
take stupid
well then you're not ready to date
you're just not ready you're
self-sabotaging yourself
right and you and the worst thing is you
know it
look at the way you're laughing right
now he removed he removed the scream i
don't see you i don't even see you
laughing
i know you laugh you look down and you
laugh girl
you know you're not ready yeah which is
why i usually don't like
wasting like people's time so like
you're
you're thinking you you think you're
you're thinking i'm 27 i should be
dating
i should be having someone but you're
not a you're not really about that
are you i'm asking the question
you know are you i just changed my
career like like about my animation so
like
so you're focused on your career so how
are you even gonna date
if you're focused on your career it's
not a bad thing boo boo
i'm not saying it is by all means focus
on what you need to focus
but what you're telling me really that's
why i didn't understand
what what you're telling me is that
you're not ready or you don't want to
you don't want to put the energy
it's what i i just want to have this
thing get i want i want to i want to
get this thing over with if i'm dating
someone and they just want to get this
thing over with
i'm not dating that person that person
is not ready
dating is complicated you have to
understand too
you have to put you have to coordinate
two people that
are not listening from the same
background don't have the same thing you
have
to put time in a relationship if you
don't have the time
maybe it's just not for you for now and
it's okay
but yeah don't don't lie to yourself boo
boo
because it's because because the way you
i don't know how i know i act yeah
no you have to put time invest time this
is not a thing
this is a relationship that you want to
have yeah you want to have that career
you want to do all that stuff well you
know i mean there's going to be
consequences if you're not able to find
a good balance so
like it's better to just probably like
especially
oh no no no we're not we're not saying
it's better to do anything
or the other we're saying there's
consequences to the choices that you
make
and based off of how you are there's
consequences that you're feeling now so
you got to find out a balance between
that or you just keep going with what
you're doing
uh but you can't have your your cake and
eat it too that's not the way this
this game works dating takes effort i'm
sorry to whoever doesn't know this but
like to all the people watching at home
will be like
i don't want to try it well you know
what i mean then if you fail i'm not
going to feel bad that's how i would be
sometimes
so so so yeah that's that's the offset
of what you're going through like i want
to go to the
what you're saying is that i want to go
to the olympics but i don't really have
time to practice
wait are you saying that dating is that
difficult sometimes sometimes
yeah so if sometimes dating sometimes
dating is difficult when you put the
time imagine when you don't even put the
time don't forget that girlfriend
there you go oh yeah i just don't like
wasting people's time i don't like
so i'm just like you know what it's
better just to not
no no no no no no no it's not about
wasting people's times how people you
want the benefits of relationship you're
not trying to put in the work
you have to put in that work the same
way you have to work hard to get your
career
you're gonna have to work at your
relationship that's how it'd be baby all
right
yeah thank you all right thank you for
coming on cheers it would be like that
it'd be like that i don't know
this this is literally the title no no
this is literally the title
of this [ __ ] life you have is
dating is trying and dating corny
and [ __ ] is not trying yeah and
you want to have you want that you have
a whole degree
you put your whole degree and you you
had time to
to study to make to take tests and stuff
like that but when it comes to
relationship you don't want to waste
people's time
come on now that's it that's what i'm
saying so so so people got to figure
that [ __ ] out but anyways i digress
uh we got nito nito what's up
yeah if you wanna just turn on your
camera we get it poppin there you go
all right all right brother what's up um
for me uh how are you doing better good
good good thank you brother
um for me i'm 25 right now
and uh i've never had that first
love kind of experience and it kind of
bothers me because like
in my circle of friends all of them have
gone through that and they were a bit
younger so i'm looking at it
at 25 how if i find it or because i'm
looking for something like that or
i'm expecting to go into something like
that with my age kind of like
sorry is he talking about dating yeah
okay cool
it's your age and the fact that you have
no experience to be a problem please go
ahead
bro if if that's what you see and they
see for
it's not because you see or you think
you see them
having first love and everything and
stuff that they actually do
you can't compare yourself to your
brethren like that what they're showing
you is that yeah it's my first loving my
you don't know what's going on behind
the closed doors that's right you don't
know i would really be you're not in
their position
so you can't compare yourself to them
like hey they have that i want that
you don't know what they really got
that's right you don't
and you can't force it either
first love happened when it happens if
you force it it's not first love
it's forced love oh bars
but at the end of the day that's pretty
much what it is you you don't know what
they have so just
just comparing yourself to people even
if you know them
you don't really know what's going on
and it will come when it will
it will come that's the thing all right
my advice is we'll say man is it going
to be harder because you're 25 and
experienced yes it's going to be harder
but guess what
it's going to get harder when you're 26
27 28 29 30 31 31 40.
you want to be a 40 holder no you don't
right so might as well just get it pop
it right now feel me
25 is not that bad obviously it's not
that much of a crazy thing
and there's a lot of women out there who
also that inexperience so just man go
out there and shoot your shot man
bro and nobody needs to know okay nobody
needs to know let me just tell you this
right now bro okay
keep it to yourself okay go out there
pretend like
you know what you're doing even if you
[ __ ] it up nobody's gonna know unless
you tell them
don't be like actually you know i uh
i've never
been with nobody knows until you say it
okay so keep that [ __ ] to yourself
all right don't [ __ ] it up don't put in
your dating profile i better not see no
ding profile
25 year old don't say it okay just keep
it to yourself
all right hold up hold on let me i'm
going to go ahead
i actually don't say or anything but it
just bothers me
it's something that bothers me okay
that's fine let it
let it bother you let it bother you let
it bother you nobody else cares that's
in your head that's between you
and your head okay so i'd say that's a
mental thing that just
nobody else is gonna know or care unless
you bring it out so just keep that to
yourself all right
whatever you don't like the way your
nose looks don't start telling everybody
nobody cares
that's between you and your nose okay so
all these thoughts that you have in here
that are always there
your insecurities it's okay to have them
that's between you
and yourself he doesn't necessarily have
to hold you back all right
cool all right thanks for coming on man
appreciate it
that's what i was be telling people bro
hey man you got insecurities nobody
cares
don't don't be telling people that you
don't like your nose that's what i'm
telling man
they don't know what i mean all right
hey hey nita nina and reid in the chat
we appreciate you sister
everybody loved the chat from yesterday
thanks for coming on
um let me do yeah let's bring some
two more people and i think we'll wrap
it up after that yeah
you know that's one thing that people
misunderstand about their their
man i i don't like the way my face looks
nobody cares who cares
nobody cares you know i've got a broken
nose right i broke her nose when i was
16 from a fight
i got this hump right there yeah and i'm
not going to fix that nobody nobody sees
it
yeah it's just you you you see it and we
don't care
all right we got uh we got brandon
brandon in the building what's up
brandon
okay oh man oh all right brandon got his
dual rag on his wave cap what's up
brother
hello excuse yeah we could hear you
what's up you good
oh [ __ ] uh hello yeah we can hear you
can you hear us
okay uh yeah i can hear y'all can y'all
see me yeah we can see you so
so what did you have for us oh okay um
so i'm in germany right i'm 22.
and i met this girl from albania and
um are you muslim are you muslim
yes sir is she muslim yes sir
okay keep going and uh
yeah she was telling me she's down and
everything you know like no matter what
happens you know it's just words but
i was wondering like um if it do um
you know go a little deeper and i end up
meeting her parents
how did i know [ __ ] how did i know okay
what did she say about her parents what
what kind of prejudice does her parents
have
all right so she was telling me like her
mom's pretty chill
and everything but her dad uh like
they're uh refugees you know they were
refugees
we're in germany right now and uh
so they fled from albania in the during
the war in like 99 or something like
that hey
hey how does your how does the dad feel
about black people just tell us
let's go that's the thing that's what's
about to say so she's telling me she
from her perspective she's telling me
he's not racist right
she's saying that he's nationalistic
meaning
she wants her to marry somebody that's
albanian not black
so i don't know if that's okay all right
all right all right i'm gonna give it to
you straight i'm gonna give it to you
sorry i knew this was coming the moment
you said she was albanian bro yeah so i
asked about your religion
okay and that's why i asked about that
because i already knew the moment you
said
you knew because i i know a lot i've met
a lot of albanians growing up okay
let's let me tell you bro her dad's
gonna want what her dad wants and
there's nothing wrong with that
okay i'm gonna say that right now my mom
wants me to marry an ethiopian person
she's not gonna be happy if i get
anything else but she'll accept it all
right he may not accept it he might be a
complete against it yeah
that's something that you have to ask if
it's worth for you to go through okay
all right you're gonna have to you know
get to that point all right because you
know
listen even though you're muslim and
it's not haram haram you know for him
it's still culturally not cultural
cultural you feel me it's not good
enough for him okay
so there's gonna be that struggle you
have to have a conversation with her and
be like yo listen if this gets
are you guys what y'all just [ __ ]
right now right
no yeah okay well for the camera cool no
no
um so y'all y'all just seeing each other
okay cool and
you guys are not in a relationship right
well we are in a relationship
that's for sure my parents know like
your parents know how long you've been
dating
come again how long you've been dating
two months
and your parents are okay all right my
man moves fast okay oh wait is this like
for you are you like looking at like
marriage like from a muslim perspective
like your parents
okay but like we're more westernized
okay okay yeah so no pork and no alcohol
but you know what i mean
girlfriends are okay okay cool all right
uh
so this is what i'm gonna say this is
what i'm gonna say she wants is she
serious about you
she's serious she's like and what has
she said about her dad
what have she said about her dad like
how she gonna handle it if you guys were
to get married what did she say
i mean she like that's pretty much the
only thing she mentioned that he's
nationalistic
she wants her uh to marry somebody
that's albanian no no
but what does she say about how she's
going to handle it like if y'all were to
get married what did she say that she
was going to do if her dad didn't accept
it
she bet she's going to leave with me
okay then then what's the issue
like my question was how do i prepare
for it and what should i
do oh go to the gym [ __ ]
you're about to get started just kidding
i'm playing
listen i'm playing okay this this is
this is a simple thing bro
okay that's her battle with her father
okay if he doesn't want a relationship
with you you got nothing to prepare for
because he don't like you you guys never
had earlier it's not like you
had a stepfather and then you realized
one day you were black and he's like oh
negros you know that's not what happened
okay
he from the jump was like nah i'm not
about that life so
that's it that's her fight you just got
to be there to support her that's it
all right but you don't have anything to
do that's her and her parents
yeah there's nothing for you to do i'll
put yourself between your f
the father and the daughter that's right
i'll say [ __ ] that's right stay in your
lane drive
that's right pump your brakes and drive
slow stay in your lane let her deal with
that
all right if he comes at you that's
another thing but he's not come come
go at your door daughter that's right
that's not you stay in your lane all
right
and just make sure he's not connected to
the albanian mafia because if he is
go to the gym all right
okay all right don't play with that okay
and no hot on before marriage
peace no bacon hey man this man came on
here talking about uh nah we not bang
your westernized muslim ass
[ __ ] out of here he did for the cameras
but you know behind closed doors
pius in the streets freaking the sheets
let's go all right we'll do one last one
that was good that was a funny one
all right we got one more all right here
we go all right we got nene in the
building
nene yourself and put the camera on
yeah we trying to see you nene stop
playing
all right oh look at you nini with your
edges on okay girl live your life damn
you're not playing with them edges
what's up
all right we got nina in the building
hey you got to turn off the the live
stream yeah turn off the live stream
can you guys see me yes man we can see
you so what's up
oh hi um okay so my question is to like
um i want to know like
what like is it a or energy like thing
that
i always attract f boys
like any time i attracted guys just
never anybody no no
no no no no it's not an aura it's not
energy
it's not magic rocks it's not it's not
none of that
it's none of that it's the people that
you let in
right i mean but the thing is like i i
say
that right and you say that too but like
i don't allow it
it's not like it's something i miss i
accept like i'm not a type of girl who
just allows someone to just disrespect
me and just treat me any type of way
but i don't know like what it is that i
keep that guys feel comfortable enough
to come in my
to come to me to do that you know what
i'm saying i don't know if it's like a
generational thing of just how guys are
nowadays or like
i don't know all right pretty squad i
don't think it's an attraction thing
because you say i don't allow them but
at the end of the day
you have the selection you're the one
that allows people in
and then after that they do what they do
but it's not
attracting there's probably a bunch of
people that you
you attract but you don't choose them
because of xyz reason
yeah yeah i mean i get that but like i
said it just feels like easier like
it's like they come to me i mean and
also too like what'd you say
what did you say it's easier what's
easier i i get
that but it's like that's what just
gravitates and comes towards me and i
mean like
i don't allow and i obviously i'm not
with the guys right but
like um what's your thing
especially as a woman you get a little
scared like you know i'm 28.
what's your type what's your type
i like everything i like everything i
like everything
i got everything okay i'm gonna ask you
something what makes them [ __ ] boys
what are they doing that's so fuckboy
um you're trying to [ __ ] already
that's fuckboy material i mean we're
grown but like my thing is always make
sure that's okay with me first
you know what i'm saying like don't just
uphold like don't just oppose that on me
and think that i'm gonna be cool you
know what i mean what what you mean how
can they just impose [ __ ] not you i
don't understand explain
like what i'm saying is like i don't
know maybe like i'm a little bit
old-fashioned but i just feel like if
you're like getting to talk to me and
you're interested
that shouldn't be like the gateway you
come out with you know what i'm saying
how many how many dates to y'all bank
until until i'm ready and i feel like it
hey man listen that doesn't make people
[ __ ] boys because they're trying to bang
you within the first three days
sorry but that that that's not that
doesn't make them [ __ ] boys that's
how most people are doing it today that
makes that makes you look good
yeah that makes sense i'm gonna say
something i'm gonna say something i'm
gonna just be very blind honest like
people be throwing out these terms like
creep and fuckboy so casually for
anything oh uh he made me simon dinner
he didn't call me back
that doesn't make him a fuckboy he just
made you a good dinner and he wasn't
that interested oh he tried to [ __ ] me
on the first three dates i don't make
him a fuckboy he was just trying to bang
because he thought you were sexually
attractive so
uh you got to also use better terms for
why because like
i'm sorry but that doesn't make somebody
a fuckboy just because they want to have
sex with you
you you do realize that people are going
to want to have sex with you
i mean yes but like what i'm saying is
like i just feel like you should at
least do your problem you should get to
know me first like
i'm not saying i'm not saying no but in
order to have sex
you it's really what i need to primarily
have sex with someone
is what i see
yeah but if i give like a perfect
example like what i'm getting at like
the first opener shouldn't be that like
of course i've tried dating apps and as
a girl
most girls could tell you it's horrible
guys are just really like disgusting on
it
like the first conversation like i had
one guy he was just like i was like
what's up
he was like so next thing i know i get
like a dick pic i'm like a great
conversation we're having
you know okay
okay okay okay the the that's just
online everyone's getting that nothing
you're doing is attracting that by
virtue of being
on an app you're gonna have weirdos who
are gonna message you okay so we're
gonna just ignore that for section i'm
talking about the dudes you're going on
a date with because that's what we're
really getting at
the dudes you want to date with they
just want to [ __ ] or they want to
[ __ ] early
and you didn't like that is that correct
yeah no yeah
okay well listen listen i'll get it and
maybe you want to and there's going to
be some guys but they're going to be
rare
and you're going to have to accept the
fact that it's going to take you longer
to look
but i'm going to be honest with you me
within the first three days like it's
going down
it's going down and if it's not i'm not
going to get mad at you i'm not going to
say nothing foul but i mean if you're
not trying to
move on my day i mean like i said it
depends like if i'm ready like if i
say we're vibing and it happens like
that soon that's fine but like
like i said like i just feel like
nowadays that's like literally like no
guy has a conversation outside but
but but again i just want you to people
what you just said you said he's a [ __ ]
boy because he wanted to
smash and you weren't there yet right
that's what you said
right that that's not a [ __ ] boy [ __ ]
boy is someone that's going to be
dissension was
to get to sex but if he's that's the one
that is straight four to six
although if i talking to you it links to
me
to another subject that we're talking
about and it's and i'm talking to the
guys
see you guys she's meeting guys and the
guys are really not trying to get to
know her and you see the reaction that
you get
she's not interested that's what it was
with the date you know having a
conversation with people
you said that you think that the guys
don't have a conversation nowadays right
yeah they don't know how to converse at
all that's just just to reinforce what
apple was saying earlier with having a
conversation with people
but you you said listen you receiving i
receive dick pics and i'm not even
dating
people just send them to me yeah imagine
you're just
out there you're gonna receive some
things like that so like i said i don't
think it has nothing to do with crystals
with magic rocks with aura with energy
with that like that
that's like the basic of things it's
going to happen unfortunately i'm not
saying it's right
would be like what can i do to like get
someone who's actually like
serious and worthwhile like i would like
to settle down
but i mean when i just don't see it
happening really because i just don't
feel like i attract anybody who
but the fact that he wants to hold up
hold on he wants to [ __ ] right away
doesn't mean that he's not serious
but yeah but but listen yeah that's
pretty much the answer
that i'll give but listen uh we're gonna
actually go to one more call but listen
we appreciate you coming on thanks
cheers okay okay
okay all right i'm gonna just say this
okay i'm gonna say this for everybody
who's watching at home
okay this is why i don't even care when
people use the word fuckboy anymore i
don't care when people use the word
creepy because that [ __ ] means nothing
to me
people be throwing out that that word
like hot kicks
ooh uh he didn't call me back [ __ ] boy
like what how's that make him a [ __ ] boy
like
y'all be just throwing these words
putting titles on people that you didn't
get along with
or that didn't want the same things that
you wanted and it's just crazy to me
it's crazy to me and you know another
thing i'm gonna say
it's not that there's not guys out there
who don't want a relationship with you
is that you didn't want relations with
those guys that wanted a relationship
with you
how many times does this girl come up
here and they said no guy really wants
to be serious with me i'm like do you
not have guys who are like genuinely
interested in you
like yeah there are some but i'm just
like they're not they're ugly
so don't say that no guys don't want a
relationship with you you don't want a
relationship with them
and when you say someone that wants to
[ __ ] that's the thing it's not all black
and white someone that wants to [ __ ]
right away
is not serious no someone that wants to
[ __ ] right away thinks you're
[ __ ]
for the yeah i mean
no i mean
yeah listen guys the way that the west
is built at the moment i'm sorry but you
know people trying to
people trying to smash if you want to
wait a bunch of dates and do all this
stuff that's fine congratulations good
for you
uh but most people are not gonna wait
that so when you say i'm having a hard
time meeting somebody who's
on that same wavelength i'm like yeah
it's not surprising most people are not
about that life but i do understand what
that that
when you're a girl you're afraid that to
engage yourself and then a person [ __ ]
right away you give it up and then after
that
he just leaves you just feel cheap and i
understand because you gave it up to
easy
i get that and that makes sense i see
that
but also one doesn't mean the other you
know
that's the thing going out there and
trying to find a mate or trying to date
is
there's a lot of there's a portion of
that it is about taking risks
you don't test the waters you don't test
you're not gonna get anything that's the
thing
uh it is a risk to take it is
now you have to decide whether you're
willing to give take that risk or not
and yeah but at the end of the day you
cannot
take that risk but you know there's
consequences of that and there's also
consequences of taking risks
it's just part of life that's what it is
[ __ ] especially in america are
not going to be out here waiting that
long
no especially in the moment they're not
going to be waiting that long so if you
want to make a way you can
but you better make sure you got the
goods to back it up because if they wait
they should this is not i'm sorry but
that's the way the sexual marketplace is
at the moment
that's the way it functions absolutely
with all this sexual liberation and all
these ladies giving it up
uh sorry but that's become commonplace
this ain't the 70s anymore hey what's up
brother
yeah we can hear you so uh what did you
want to yeah i didn't uh
if you could just turn on the camera and
then we'll get it popping
cool
all right yes so tk what what uh what do
you want to say
uh okay here we go okay now we can
so you got a radio voice bro this is
crazy touched on the uh
subject i guess uh that we've already
uh that if i was gonna ask wrote some
down entered it i had to re-uh
delete it and then discord kicks me out
or whatever but um
i feel like there's a certain type of
healthy giving up
where maybe like a revival or just
getting into
solitude i kind of feel like uh
i should just remove all influence but
then i feel like that might be an
unhealthy thing to do to just
be so far removed but that's that's
where a point where i'm feeling
uh in life is where like if i'm not
successful
i gotta completely gotta cut out i gotta
i gotta go
you gotta you gotta go internal
yeah i'm always i'm always destroying
and rebuilding my personality
and i feel like that's not healthy
oh bro i don't know this sounds like
something for a shrink my friend i don't
even know what that means what do you
mean you're destroying and rebuilding
your personality
[ __ ]
i i don't know what that means i think
i'm always going through experiments
to try and further develop my
personality because i feel like
it isn't at a maturity level or
something i'm always trying to
put myself in situations where i can
progress but i'm
i'm at a i'm at a wall
why are you at a wall
um i feel like i'm not being my best
self potentially but then also just
yeah i was going to write that i feel
very alienated
and thinking back to relationships that
i've had
i've often felt like why am i even here
or just i felt like
yeah just in general just didn't feel
fulfilled or successful
okay i'm not sure what the question is
in here because i feel like you're just
giving us a lot of problems
and different problems to unpack and um
and you got you got to pick one because
i this is a lot
so if i have a lot of problems do i
do i have the answer inside
um i mean you are generally and your
behaviors are generally the answer to
those issues but
um you may not know how to proceed so
that that's where i think therapy comes
to place to kind of help unpack why you
have certain issues but i do believe
that most of us have the the
the in most cases most of us have the
answers to our problems yes i do i do
believe that
uh preach what do you think you just
have to reorganize and sometimes you
need help to reorganize
that's why there's therapy that's why
there's uh people that can
professionals that can actually help you
with that sometimes yeah
the the answers are within but you need
help to find them and sometimes that's
that
sometimes you have to visit someone and
you know
there's no stigma to having a shrink or
whatever what not you know
i'm i'm i'm a consult i'm in the in
in the process of consulting you know
because
that's that's that's what they are for
to rearrange yourself sometimes you
can feel lost and stuff like that
there's some people that are going to be
able to
reassess that therapy
yeah and that's what they're there for
you go to therapy i'm i'm setting up to
go
i go to therapy definitely you have i
don't think there's a stigma to that and
you
everybody i think everybody should go to
therapy whether you think you have a
problem or you don't
yep you understand what i'm saying so
sometimes i would i would definitely
suggest you to go to therapy to assist
that with someone that is
that can actually direct you and help
you go within
and find the confidence and find find
what what
what the issues are or where the issues
stem from yeah
yeah you know it's like uh to me it's
like it's like
it's almost like a workout for your
brain you know it's like it's kind of
sometimes it's kind of hard to see
because you're so close to the problems
it's kind of hard to see them with any
kind of perspective right so uh
that's where i think i go to therapy to
kind of just give a bit of distance for
myself and
sometimes they give me the advice and
i'm like oh i [ __ ] i knew that but i
was so close to it i couldn't figure it
out
so that's where yeah that's where that's
where that kind of stuff helps in so
i would i would definitely recommend
that you look into that but you know
what i tell you is that as for your
first question are you the answer to
your problems undoubtedly
uh but it doesn't change the fact that
some of us need guidance a lot of us
need guidance on a lot of these issues
and there's nothing wrong with you
needing that as well
i appreciate that yeah no problem you
got a great radio voice bro i don't know
i don't know if you're using that for
making money or something bro but you
you should bro if you if you did like
asmr [ __ ] like
you'd be killing the game right now no
lie
all right so if you destroy your
personality again just rebuild it as an
asmr youtuber all right
okay all right i appreciate you guys
no problem that [ __ ] was crazy that
man's voice was like so radio and [ __ ]
me up no there's some girls out there
i'd be like oh my god who's this
hey just because of the voice just
because that's because of the voice yeah
yeah yeah it was just like okay a
hundred a hundred all right let me just
read up a couple of these
stop saying like like like all right
cool thanks
uh good advice value values
i learned how to be better human from
y'all hey man we appreciate it
hearing all this i wish i had y'all when
i was in high school it's amazing
uh thank you man hope y'all getting on
chat
is it discord how y'all oh yeah the
check the description for more
information the conversation is only as
good as you make it
there are good guys out there ladies
they're not just dick pics i i i
entirely agree there's definitely a lot
of guys like that out there
is there any notes you want to say about
stuff you want to would you
go ahead tell me no no no god no no no
no no no no no no no no would you i got
no no
you said would you we all know you had
something what was it would you
would you would you would you buy time
would you walk like a champion talk like
a champion
i wanna be somebody
a couple weeks ago yeah a couple of
weeks ago a girl's uh i was talking this
girl from the uk
right and she was like man you yeah yeah
man i like a lot of uk music and i was
like oh
i was like where that's cool that's cool
yeah but you probably don't know most
most foreigners don't know nothing about
uk music and i had to stunt on her
no no but i had to stunt on her you feel
me
so you already know what i had to do
they think
yo yo
you already know what i had to do right
all right you already know what i had to
do right
that's right you know what i had to do
right yeah put it on
okay yo ruff let's do this right now oh
hi okay you want to do [ __ ] too
yo let's go why do you think i'm telling
you this story i know
you think i'm not gonna give you credit
yo let's go you think i'm not gonna give
you credit
you think i would give you credit bro
let's go
let's go man that [ __ ] oh yo
it's that one yeah that one
[Music]
it's better because of the other video
oh thank you that's a good point
i just thought he normally talks that
fast
[Music]
y'all about the scene you can't even go
ahead tell them preachers
go the energy i love i love when they
start the beast
and then they wheel it up it's because
we try to recreate the energy
that you wear and that's part of like
jamaicans and you know the island
the island they really do that the
english islands they really do that in
it
and that's the thing when they wheel up
when they bring back a beat it's because
they went
uh so much of a level of heightness that
they had to yo
way little bring it back again all right
here play pattern selector
you notice this that's what it's for we
want to relive that moment
all right
some of the craziest things i've ever
seen
you see how hype it was it was so high
people were not ready the first time you
understand
people were not being able to to enjoy
it
the first time they were not able to so
you know what
just to get everybody on the same now
you know what this is about
right you know where we're going all
right so now you're able to properly get
hyped with the rest of us yeah here
cause you know where it is
wheel it up play back again select her
play the beat now
and then he plays it and then
okay you know what it is
[Music]
ready
people
yo yo bro look how look how much he's
sweating bro
three minutes let's go
respected
forget this [ __ ] i got i i i i i had to
show my life to some of my people
okay you know what i'm saying let's go
general
let's go yo you don't even understand
how this
yo this [ __ ] is deep my man was popping
off bro
yo that's that's that's some some jungle
music some some some
back in the days things here yeah but
yeah they think we don't know about you
but
i like music period you know what i'm
saying i like music
period like
yeah if you said they don't know nothing
about uk
what what yep no you don't know
no we big we big fans because you want
to show some love to the uk
brethren yeah i think it was dizzy
rascals in the back it was like a whole
bunch
a whole bunch of people in the bag that
you you know yeah prince you love
dancehall
i love love preach listen listen listen
if you get this man talking about dance
hall i'd just be sitting down like poor
[ __ ] let's go
yo the dancehall thing that's my yo
that is i am not a
friend yeah yeah he could go all day me
me i [ __ ] with uk garage and some
ukraine being some of the afro but like
you know like a bit of grime not too
much but he he's way more verse than i
am so
maybe one day we'll we'll get on that
tip and get on that tip
but uh but yeah we want to just end it
on a hype note uh show some love to the
people from the uk
all right uh folks in jamaica but uh
massive
or the island massive that's right and
tobago barbados right here
all of them people from the vinica
everybody around the world
people from the so-called everybody in
the in the
uk massive you know manchester
all right man peace hope you guys
enjoyed today's stream we'll be back
next sunday with a different guest
so be sure to check that out and uh yes
that's it for today